Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 132.
Ausgabe von UKW, dem Podcast, der versucht einen Blick zu werfen auf, ja,
man kann mittlerweile sagen, die Krisen der Welt oder sagen wir mal zumindest all diese Vorgänge,
die sich immer so abspielen und wo man nicht so genau den Finger draufhalten
kann, wann die denn jetzt eigentlich mal so richtig angefangen haben,
geschweige denn, wann sie aufgehört haben.
Und heute geht es mal nicht um die Ukraine, wie es denn hier so oft der Fall
ist, sondern wir schlagen mal ein anderes Kapitel auf, was ich sehr interessant
fand, was in gewisser Hinsicht aber auch wieder mal mit allem zu tun hat.
Und zwar geht der Blick heute nach Serbien.
Deswegen, weil es in Serbien seit einigen Monaten ziemlich wilde Proteste gibt
und was es denn damit so auf sich hat, darüber sprechen wir heute mit Dejan Mihalovic.
Hallo Dejan, herzlich willkommen bei UKW.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung, freue mich dabei sein zu können.
Dejan, du bist jetzt kein Geschichtsprofessor und eigentlich auch kein politischer
Kommentator trotzdem bist du mir ein bisschen ins Auge gefallen zuletzt weil
du doch sehr engagiert zumindest über die Vorgänge in Serbien schreibst im Netz,
erklär uns doch mal was so dein Verhältnis zu dem Thema ist und wie es dazu
gekommen ist dass du dich dieses Themas annimmst.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich bin tatsächlich jetzt nicht der Experte für Serbien,
sondern letztendlich ein Mensch mit Internet und schreibe Dinge ins Internet.
Das habe ich immer schon getan.
Und als diese ganzen Sachen in Serbien begonnen haben, habe ich die natürlich
dann verfolgt, wie viele andere
auch, über das, was erstmal so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung da war.
Habe dann natürlich festgestellt, okay, es ist relativ wenig medial im deutschsprachigen Raum vorhanden.
Habe dann angefangen, die dementsprechend medial nochmal umzuschwenken und dann
zu gucken, was wird eigentlich in Serbien berichtet.
Habe dann für mich einfach in Instagram entdeckt, dass da relativ viel berichtet wird über Instagram.
Das heißt, dass man da relativ viel Material rankommt, Informationen rankommt,
teilweise aus direkter Quelle eben auch.
Also wie man es aus dem Netz so kennt. Und habe dann dementsprechend mich da,
bin da so eingetaucht und habe irgendwann festgestellt, dass eigentlich ziemlich
viel dahinter so stattfindet, was sehenswert, hörenswert ist.
Vor allem in der Verbindung mit meinem sonstigen beruflichen Kontext und ehrenamtlichen
Bestrebungen und der Frage, wie man Demokratien irgendwie stärken kann, schützen kann.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja gut, wenn so viel da vorhanden ist,
aber nicht im deutschsprachigen Raum vorhanden ist, dann lass doch einfach Dinge
rauspicken und übersetzen und so zugänglich machen.
Und so hat es begonnen oder so habe ich angefangen, eben Dinge immer so exemplarisch
rauszupicken und zu erklären, was da stattfindet, wieso das stattfindet,
so eine kleine Einordnung mitzugeben im Rahmen meiner Möglichkeiten,
und so vielleicht einfach eben Zugang zu einer breiteren Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen,
der einfach medial so nicht gegeben ist.
Dein Name legt es ja schon nahe. Du hast eine besondere Verbindung zu Serbien,
sprichst die Sprache auch.
Erläuter doch mal so ein bisschen, was dein Verhältnis zu Serbien ist.
Ja, ich habe natürlich auch eine Staatsbürgerschaft, eine serbische.
Ich habe eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft, also eine serbische und eine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ich bin in dem ehemaligen Jugoslawien geboren. Mein Vater, das heißt meine Eltern,
die Hälfte meiner Eltern, das heißt meine Vaterlicherseits, die ganze Familie,
die kommt eben aus dem Bereich, aus Belgrad, das heißt Opa, Europa und so weiter.
Und dementsprechend habe ich eine sehr enge Bindung auch an die Stadt.
Und dementsprechend auch in den Teil eben Jugoslawiens, weil wir einfach da
relativ viel auch Zeit verbracht haben.
Ich habe als Kind da eine Zeit lang gelebt, habe auch da tatsächlich auch Militärdienst
ableisten müssen nach dem Abitur
in Deutschland, weil ich keine doppelte Staatswirtschaft damals hatte.
Und da gab es einfach die Wahl nach dem Abitur, ich mache Militärdienst oder
ich mache Militärdienst. Und dann habe ich dann für Militärdienst entschieden.
Und so war das leider zu der Zeit.
Und genau und dann bin ich wieder zurückgekommen und war natürlich jetzt dann
immer wieder mal unten aber ich muss auch zugeben,
das ist tatsächlich glaube ich auch vielleicht so ein Aspekt mit dem was jetzt
gerade so stattfindet ich war letztes Jahr also 24 im Februar war ich wieder,
nach 15 Jahren also ich war 15 Jahre lang nicht in Serbien nach 15 Jahren war
ich dann wieder in Serbien weil meine Tochter einfach ihre Wurzeln oder die
Wurzeln ihres Vaters das ich auch immer kennenlernen wollte.
Und da habe ich ihn für mich so gemerkt und mich auch gefragt,
wieso ich so lange nicht da war.
Und so ein bisschen war es, glaube ich, auch so ein Abstand halten,
um gesund zu bleiben, weil mich das einfach belastet hat.
Immer was da passiert und wie die Lage da ist. Und ich irgendwie das Gefühl
hatte, da gibt es nämlich keine Hoffnung, dass in dem, also was da vorliegt
an Staat, an Gesellschaft, an Strukturen, dass man dann Demokratie irgendwie hinbekommt.
Und Demokratie, wie ich sie als Demokratie bezeichnen würde.
Und 15 Jahre warst du nicht da, rechnen wir mal ein bisschen,
also 2010, 2009 warst du dann sozusagen davor da.
Du lebst ja jetzt in Freiburg, also du bist sozusagen schon gefühlt immer hier.
Sag doch nochmal ein bisschen was zu deiner Arbeit, du hast es ja schon angedeutet,
zu Demokratie, was ist da dein Verhältnis?
Ja, also beruflich bin ich hauptsächlich Referent für Demokratiebildung und
SV, SMV und bin aber auch zeitgleich Referent für digitale Transformation.
Und Barcamps mache ich dann im Prinzip auch relativ viel. Das heißt,
ich habe so zwei Schnittflächen, die auch wiederum mit dem, was da passiert,
also meist mit vielen Dingen, die ich im Prinzip mache, immer so eine Schnittfläche
bilden, weil Demokratie und Demokratiebildung einfach immer auch im Kontext
von digitaler Transformation stattfindet.
Und viele Prozesse und Dinge, die man so eben mitbekommt, global,
da hängen halt beide Themen mit drin.
Und die sind eigentlich tatsächlich gar nicht so voneinander trennbar.
Und das heißt, ich bin da jetzt im Institut, wo ich also Fortbildung konzipiere
oder auch entwickle oder auch durchführe, viel mit Schulleitung arbeite,
viel mit Lehrkräften, mit Schulen, auch mit Schülern gemeinsam.
Und ich habe noch nebenher einfach so Baustellen, ehrenamtlich,
also ich war jetzt auch vier Jahre im Vorstand von D64 zum Beispiel,
habe ich eben dementsprechend auch in Bezug auf Digitalität mich immer engagiert,
mache es sich weiter im Prinzip auch mache.
Und im Endeffekt ist die für mich immer die Frage über all die Jahre immer,
die ich so vorhin gesagt habe, wie schafft man es eigentlich,
eine Demokratie möglichst stark aufzustellen?
Was heißt eine Demokratie eigentlich im heutigen Zeitalter? Das heißt,
wie muss ich die Demokratie auch weiterentwickeln, um eben auch dann stark weiterhin zu bleiben,
also was wäre so eine progressive Demokratie und zeitgleich auch,
wie kann man eine Demokratie auch wehrhaft gestalten mit all den Herausforderungen,
die sich in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten entwickelt haben.
Ja, da haben wir ja gerade ein schönes Beispiel in den USA, wie es auch mal
wieder nicht funktionieren kann.
Ich denke mal, das dürftest du auch ziemlich intensiv verfolgen.
Was macht das so mit jemandem, der an diesem Thema dran ist?
Es ist irre. Es ist eigentlich insofern frustrierend, dass man einfach,
wenn ich ehrlich bin, vor zehn Jahren oder so, weiß noch, da hatte ich irgendwie
doch so die Hoffnung, auch jetzt mit D64 und anderen Vereinen oder sonstigen
Institutionen oder Menschen, die sich in dem Bereich engagieren,
hatte ich noch so die Hoffnung, dass man vielleicht in die Politik hinein so
ein bisschen reinwirken kann und vielleicht schaffen kann, auch im Bundestag
oder in anderen Parlamenten einfach Menschen zu erreichen und zu erklären.
Wie zentral und wie wesentlich einfach Digitalität ist und einfach unser Leben bestimmt.
Es ist leider nicht gelungen. Und letzten Endes haben wir jetzt dann einfach auch Folgen dessen.
Das heißt, dass wir Menschen haben, die einfach nie durchdrungen haben,
welche Bedeutung das Ganze hat.
Und jetzt ist wahrscheinlich, einige verstehen, wie wesentlich dann einfach
gewisse Akteure sind und gewisse Player im globalen Kontext einfach sind und
welche Rolle Digitalität einfach spielt.
Welche Abhängigkeiten damit geschaffen wurden über Jahrzehnte und wie schwer
es einfach ist, davon sich irgendwie jetzt zu lösen, zu befreien und ja,
was anderes irgendwie als Lösung zu finden.
Ja, guter Punkt. Ich erinnere mich auch noch sehr gut, als es losging mit dem arabischen Frühling.
Da war das ja dann auch so, oh ja,
jetzt hier die Leute können über Twitter und Facebook kommunizieren und ich
glaube, viele von uns, da nehme ich mich selber auch nicht aus,
haben so ein bisschen so diese Hoffnung gehabt, Wenn dann erstmal diese alternativen
Kommunikationskanäle da sind, dann werden die Leute sich zusammentun und das Gute bewirken.
Ich glaube, das war eine relativ naive Sicht auf die Dinge.
Es gibt zwar diesen Faktor, definitiv.
Aber es hat sich glaube ich herausgestellt, dass der potenzielle Missbrauch,
so Stichwort Fake News etc.
Und das Aufhetzen von Leuten einfach noch sehr viel mehr Power entwickelt,
wenn man dem halt nicht von vornherein einen Riegel vorschiebt bzw.
Das bewusst verfolgt und dann eben auch ernst nimmt.
Und es gab ja dann auch sehr schnell sehr viele Negativbeispiele von erstmal
der akuten Verfolgung der Leute, die sich quasi im Netz öffentlich machen und
wie man das in Syrien dann auch sehr stark gesehen hat.
Myanmar, es gibt ja zahlreiche Beispiele in dieser Hinsicht.
Naja und jetzt eben auch die Entwicklung hin zu so einer totalen faktenverdrehten
Welt, in der irgendwie nichts mehr wahr ist.
Und die Leute einfach in diese Desorientierung abgleiten und dann halt einfach,
keine Ahnung, irgendeinen Scheiß glauben.
Und das, ja, ich denke mal, das wird ja sicherlich jetzt hier auch in Serbien
ein Thema sein, aber das ist jetzt auch gar nicht das, worauf wir uns fokussieren wollen.
Aber ich kann verstehen, dass das extrem frustrierend ist. Finde ich ja auch extrem frustrierend.
Aber du wirst dich wundern, es wird später eine Rolle spielen in unserem Gespräch
und tatsächlich gerade die andere Rolle, die du angesprochen hast.
Das heißt, interessanterweise ist in Serbien spielt tatsächlich Digitalität,
gerade die demokratische, die Empowernde im Prinzip Rolle.
Okay, gut zu wissen. Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal auf Serbien zu sprechen.
Ich will keinen Geschichtsvortrag halten, aber es ist vielleicht mal ganz gut
zu Beginn nochmal so ein paar Pflöcke einzuschlagen, weil ich merke auch an mir selber.
Und ich übertrage das jetzt einfach mal auf viele. Serbien ist ja so ein bisschen,
und der gesamte Balkan in gewisser Hinsicht, aber Serbien nochmal mehr als die anderen Länder,
das liegt so ein bisschen im Windschatten, das kriegen viele irgendwie nicht auf die Kette.
Die Wahrnehmung wirst du sicherlich auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise auch gemacht haben.
Während natürlich die Orientierung nach Westeuropa in der Bundesrepublik relativ
stark ist und es dann halt im Osten in abgeschwächter Form zumindest die Existenz
und die Realität der anderen Staaten zur Kenntnis genommen wird.
So Polen, natürlich jetzt eben auch durch den Konflikt die Ukraine,
das war sicherlich definitiv auch so ein weißer Fleck auf der Landkarte,
das ist er natürlich mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Aber so mit dem Balkan, glaube ich, da ist noch sehr viel davon,
von dieser Ausblendung vorhanden.
Es mag die Ausnahme geben, so Kroatien, Slowenien,
die halt dann doch ein bisschen näher herangerückt sind, aber so Serbien,
Montenegro, die Gebiete sind, glaube ich, für viele Leute so ein bisschen so
ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
Bei Serbien kommt natürlich nochmal dazu, dass dann auch nochmal mit der anderen
Schrift und dieser Nähe zu Russland,
dass alles immer sehr verstärkend wirkt und natürlich ist Serbien auch so als
Faktor in den Konflikten der letzten 30 Jahre natürlich auch.
Hat eine sehr unrühmliche Rolle gespielt.
Es ging ja dann los mit diesem Kosovo-Konflikt,
also im Nachgang der Auflösung der Sowjetunion musste natürlich auch Jugoslawien
sich neu finden, beziehungsweise hat sich dann nicht mehr gefunden und ist eben zerfallen,
während eben Slowenien als sehr westliches Land, Ich war jetzt gerade erst vor
kurzem da, wenn man da rumfährt, dann ist das irgendwie wie Österreich,
Deutschland, Italien, so eine Mischung irgendwie auseinander.
Das hat sich ja quasi sofort verabschiedet und gesagt, so Leute,
macht euren Scheiß alleine, wir sind dann mal weg und das wurde ja dann auch
von den anderen Ländern irgendwie mehr oder weniger einfach so akzeptiert,
weil man glaube ich schon immer wusste, dass Slowenien eigentlich gar nicht so richtig dazugehört.
Dann kam es zu den Kriegen zwischen Serbien und Kroatien, Bosnien, Herzegowina etc.
Und am Ende dann halt so 1995 der finale Zerfall.
Dann brodelt es eine Weile, dann gab es diesen Konflikt mit dem Kosovo,
also der Region Serbiens, die stark albanisch geprägt ist und unter Slobodan
Milosevic kam es dann eben dort wieder zu diesem Konflikt und dem Wunsch,
das Kosovo sich wieder einzuverleiben,
immer mit diesem Konflikt.
Ewigen Hinweis auf Geburtsstädte Serbiens, diese Geschichtsverklärung von irgendwelchen
Ereignissen vor tausend Jahren,
die am Ende ja eigentlich für niemanden wirklich eine Rolle spielen.
Nichtsdestotrotz war es ein Konflikt, auch weil es natürlich eine serbische Minderheit dort gab.
Dann ist halt die NATO eingeschritten, hat gesagt so bis hierhin und nicht weiter,
was ja am Ende dann auch zum Fall von Milosevic und auch dessen Überstellung
an den internationalen Gerichtshof führte, wo er dann gestorben ist.
Und dann war es sozusagen so ein bisschen unklar, was denn jetzt eigentlich
passiert und ich denke zu dem Zeitpunkt ist dann aber auch so die Aufmerksamkeit
auf diese Region, zumindest jetzt in unserem Bereich, im deutschsprachigen Raum,
so ein bisschen auf Null runtergefahren.
Wie hast du denn sozusagen den Weg jetzt ab da, so ab der Jahrtausendwende so wahrgenommen?
Ach, schwierig, ey. Wenn ich ehrlich bin, das, was du jetzt gerade so zusammengefasst
hast, gibt es natürlich an jeder Stelle, können wir nochmal irgendwie reingehen
und diskutieren und das aufdröseln.
Aber darum soll es ja heute gar nicht gehen.
Jetzt, ich würde es tatsächlich eher kurzfassen, um möglichst viel Zeit zu bekommen,
um Zeit zu haben, auch uns mit den aktuellen, mit der aktuellen Sachlage auseinanderzusetzen.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, die Zeit danach war für mich einfach ein,
ein so ein Peak oder eine Person, die für mich so rausgestochen ist in der ganzen
Geschichte, war der Jinjic.
Das heißt, er ist für mich persönlich einfach, das will ich nicht,
eine persönliche Geschichte noch mal für mich gewesen, herausgestochen,
weil er einfach in Deutschland studiert hat.
Und ich dann dementsprechend das mit ihm irgendwie, also ich konnte es irgendwie
so relaten und sagen, okay, schau, scheinbar geht das.
Das heißt, in Deutschland studieren und dann irgendwie zurückkommen und dann
einfach das Wissen oder die Erfahrung, die er gemacht hat, vielleicht irgendwie
hier einfließen zu lassen.
Das heißt, er hat sich zum Beispiel stark eben gegen Korruption eingesetzt.
Er hat ganz viele Vorschläge gemacht, die sich auch jetzt den ähneln,
die heute die studentischen Proteste im Prinzip auszeichnen.
Und er wurde aber dann irgendwann auch erschossen.
Also man muss dazu sagen, Soran Tudyvich war quasi Premierminister nach Slobodan Milosevic.
Kostunitscha war Präsident zu der Zeit, später dann sein Nachfolger.
Und er war dann von 2001 bis 2003 Premierminister.
Und dann wurde er erschossen von, weiß nicht, hat man die Leute dann gefunden?
Ja, es gibt auch da, man weiß eigentlich schon, aus welchen Kreisen das kam.
Also welche Menschen dahinter waren und.
Man weiß, auch diese Aufklärung dieser Geschichte zum Beispiel auch so ein Punkt,
also deswegen, alle Sachen, die du vorhin genannt hast, letzten Endes schwingen
die so mit, so als gewisse, an gewissen Stellen auch heute.
Das heißt, also all das hat irgendwo doch so einen Kontext, hat eine Rolle in
einem gewissen größeren Kontext.
Und er war auch Bürgermeister, Oberbürgermeister von Belgrad,
das war er tatsächlich auch.
Das heißt, dementsprechend hat er da nochmal die Verbundenheit hergemacht.
Er hat zum Beispiel auch eine Universität gegründet in Novipasar.
Das spielt zum Beispiel auch eine Rolle dann später im Gespräch.
Da war zum Beispiel auch eine große Demo.
Und ist zum Beispiel ein Teil Serbiens, wo eben die Bevölkerung größtenteils
muslimische Serben sind.
Das heißt, es gab einfach viele Dinge, die er im Endeffekt gemacht hat,
die man schon als progressiv bezeichnen kann.
Und dann durch die Ermordung von ihm war für mich dann eben so ein Punkt,
auch dann, okay, nee, also scheinbar dann doch nicht.
Das heißt, scheinbar ist dann so ein Weg, so ein progressiver Weg eben hier nicht möglich.
Und das war für mich persönlich dann zum Beispiel auch so ein Punkt,
wo ich dann für mich entschieden habe, ich werde nicht zurückkehren.
Ich habe tatsächlich mit dem Gedanken gespielt, nach Bayer gerade zurückzukehren und da zu leben.
Und dann war bei mir der Punkt, wo ich dachte, okay, also wenn dann alles,
was irgendwie progressiv ist, dann so eingegangen wird, oder wenn man versucht,
sich gegen Korruption einzusetzen, dass dann auch die Sache droht,
dass man dementsprechend dann erschossen wird und ich muss dazu sagen,
ich habe auch persönlich Erfahrungen gemacht in Belgrad zu der Zeit auch mit.
Leuten aus kriminellen Bereichen, die jetzt nicht so optimal waren und da war
für mich einfach klar, okay, das ist für mich nicht etwas, was Zukunft hat.
Und dann war es mal ganz lang eben, ja, also ich habe das dann schon verfolgt,
was dann passiert ist, auch jetzt mit Vucic dann, wie er in die Macht gekommen
ist und Und wie das dann sich entwickelt hat.
Aber es war dann eher so mit einem gewissen Abstand versehen.
Und letztendlich hat es dann bestätigt, was ich so für mich so ausgelegt habe,
in welche Richtung sich wahrscheinlich das Land entwickeln wird.
Genau, also es gab ja dann sozusagen so eine zweite Phase, also wenn es nach
2000, nach Milosevic erstmal so eine pro-westliche Liberalisierungsphase gab,
ging die dann mit Zinzic ja nicht sofort unter.
Es gab dann noch Boris Tadic als Präsident,
der glaube ich auch eher als pro-europäisch angesehen werden kann.
Aber dann so um 2012 kam dann der Tomislav Nikolic wurde dann Präsident und
Vucic wurde dann 2014 Premierminister und beide eigentlich eher so mit diesem
national-konservativen,
nationalistischen Feld zuzuordnen.
Und im Falle von Vucic halt auch eine relativ starke,
Ja, so ein Verhältnis auch zu Russland und das ist ja so ein bisschen dieser schwierige Bereich.
Also auf der einen Seite hieß es immer so, ja Serbien orientiert sich irgendwie
nach Europa, aber dann halt irgendwie trotzdem immer dieses starke Verhältnis zu Russland.
Also was hat sich durch Vucic dann verändert?
Ich muss dazu wissen, dass er tatsächlich auch schon viel länger,
also bevor er jetzt auch offiziell an der Macht war, einfach schon seine Finger
mit drin hatte. Das heißt, er war ja auch mit Lorschwitscher mit dabei.
Und das heißt, deswegen, es ist sehr viel intransparent an vielen Stellen.
Es gibt auch viele so Geschichten, die erzählt werden, wo ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht prüfen kann oder prüfen konnte, inwiefern die wahr sind, nicht wahr sind.
Aber wo man schon ableiten kann dass er schon relativ früh relativ viel Mitsprache
hatte und eine gewisse Wirkung hatte und Macht hatte und jetzt zum russischen
Verhältnis ich würde es mal wieder auch da runterbrechen wollen,
um es nicht zu ausführlich zu machen.
Ich würde Vucic heute so beschreiben dass er letzten Endes eigentlich so ein
klassischer Autokrat ist das heißt letzten Endes hat er einfach,
macht Befugnisse in alle Bereiche hinein und letzten Endes macht er das, was ihm dient.
Und das, was mich so, was ich so interessant finde, ist eigentlich,
ich habe lange Zeit, habe ich nicht verstanden, wie es sein kann,
dass zum Beispiel die USA und Russland miteinander können.
Also das heißt, dass dann eben jetzt so ein Trump mit dem Putin zum Beispiel
oder gewisse Kräfte, also autokratische Kräfte mit dem im Prinzip können,
Weil ich bin einfach groß geworden und sozialisiert worden und habe es in der Schule gelernt,
dass diese zwei Blöcke, das Ost- und Westblock, und dann haben die sich bekämpft
und es waren einfach gewisse Werte dahinter und so weiter.
Und jetzt gibt es aber halt eine Verknüpfung, diese autokratische,
ist letzten Endes dann diese Oligarchie. Das heißt, einfach Menschen mit scheiß
viel Kohle und Macht schauen im Endeffekt, wie sie diese Macht weiter erhalten können.
Und eigentlich ist im Endeffekt diese ökonomische Vernetzung,
das ist das, was eigentlich die bindet miteinander.
Das heißt, eigentlich wollen die im Endeffekt Macht, gebunden mit Geld an gewissen Punkten.
Wollen sie erhalten. Und dementsprechend machen sie alles, was ihnen dient.
Und wenn man es natürlich jetzt sagt, ich würde mich jetzt mal kurz verabschieden
von allem, was national erzählt wird, nach dem Motto, dass eben,
gehen wir davon aus, Putin wäre jetzt gar nicht so wichtig, also Russland gar
nicht so wichtig, das Volk gar nicht so wichtig.
Und wir gehen davon aus, dass Trump jetzt die Amerika und das amerikanische
Volk nicht so wichtig wäre.
Wir gehen davon aus, wenn wir Menschen ja eigentlich Macht haben wollen und
an Macht bleiben wollen und reich sein wollen, weil sie es gleich noch ein bisschen
Geld oder Finanzen wie auch immer im Prinzip brauchen, um diese Macht weiterhin
ausleben zu können oder halten zu können.
Dann stellt man im Endeffekt eine Gemeinsamkeit fest.
Und das ist tatsächlich das, was letztendlich global die alle so miteinander ins Spiel bringt.
Wieso zum Beispiel auch Daniel Vucic eben Kontakte pflegt in die USA,
Kontakte pflegt, also in Trump-USA, Kontakte pflegt in Putin-Russland,
Kontakte pflegt nach China.
Das heißt, er pflegt im Endeffekt Kontakte in alle Richtungen.
Was jetzt im alten Verständnis nicht nachvollziehbar wäre, man sagt,
das sind völlig verschiedene Systeme, aber nach dem Verständnis autokratischen
Denken, von der autokratischen Logik her gedacht, ergibt es durchaus Sinn.
Weil letztendlich wiederum jeder schaut so, wie er für sich irgendwie einen
Vorteil daraus gewinnen kann. Das heißt, man macht einfach Deals,
die wiederum dem eigenen Land dienen.
Das heißt, der Deal, der im Prinzip dann mit den USA schließt oder mit Russland
schließt, mit den Chinesen schließt, heißt halt immer, beide Seiten gewinnen dann.
Und beide Seiten heißt aber, die Menschen, die in der Autokratie davon profitieren.
Die profitieren davon. Das heißt, die Bevölkerung letzten Endes nicht.
Und das ist so, wo ich sagen würde, dieses pro-russische aktuell beschrieben,
würde ich jetzt sagen, ist das die Verbindung, die einfach da ist.
Die ist völlig sattig betrachtet eine rein autokratische Verbindung.
Die geschichtliche Kontext, jetzt Sprache, Kultur und so weiter,
ist eine andere Nummer und ist auch völlig losgelöst von Vucic zu betrachten.
Und das ist tatsächlich durchaus komplex.
Weil auch dann natürlich Jugoslawien nochmal eine andere Rolle gespielt,
hat im Vergleich zu anderen Satellitenstaaten, auch unter Tito eine andere Rolle gespielt hat.
Das heißt, also da hat immer Jugoslawien eine Sonderrolle gehabt und auch heute
würde ich sagen, dass eben Serbien mit auch da nochmal eine andere Rolle und
eine Sonderrolle im Prinzip hat, wenn man nicht vergleichbar ist mit anderen Staaten.
Ja, ich meine, ich finde das eine gute Aufstellung, die du machst,
weil das sieht man jetzt bei Trump ja ganz deutlich.
Es gibt da so eine, ich nenne es eigentlich mal Mafia,
so Leute, die halt einfach die Wesentlichen für sich selber arbeiten und dann
einfach so eine Rolle als Staatspräsident ist dann ganz praktisch,
um sozusagen all diese ganzen Deals zu machen.
Da hat man einfach einen ganz anderen Reach, als wenn man jetzt nur so privat
unterwegs ist und diese Leute, die verstehen sich irgendwie.
Also die wissen, ah ja, du bist genauso korrupt wie wir.
Wir sprechen eine Sprache und die halt nicht mehr in Blöcken oder in demokratischen
Positionierungen oder auch nur langfristigen Entwicklungen denken.
Also klar, Putin mag 10 Jahre, 20, 30 bis am Ende seines Lebens Plan im Kopf
haben, aber eben jetzt nicht mit wohin entwickelt sich mein Land und wie geht es allen besser,
sondern halt einfach nur alles ist definiert von Macht und Einflussnahme und
von daher auch alles sehr kurz gedacht.
Wen man da wahrscheinlich auch noch nennen kann, ist auch Erdogan,
der genau ähnlich auftritt und diese Länder bilden dann irgendwie ungewollt,
so unterschiedlich sie auch sind, eine Achse.
Und deswegen stimmt auf einmal Trump halt auch mit Nordkorea irgendwie in der
UN ab. Es ist einfach wirklich vollkommen verrückt, wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt.
Ja, Geopolitik ist einfach tatsächlich, eigentlich kann man sie ökonomisch,
ganz stark ökonomisch betrachten.
Und dann eben, wie gesagt, in diesem oligarchischen, autokratischen Gedanken.
Autokratie letzten Endes ist im Endeffekt dann einfach dieses Gerüst,
was dem Ganzen einfach dann eben eine Funktion gibt oder eine Struktur gibt.
Das heißt, über Autokratien kann ich das halt umsetzen, weil einfach dann die
Machtverhältnisse dann so gegeben sind, dass das funktioniert.
So, jetzt ist der Vucec ja seit 2017 dann der Präsident.
Also man muss vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutern, wie das in Serbien so funktioniert.
Also es gibt so eine Machtverteilung zwischen Präsident und Premierminister.
Der Präsident wird letztlich vom Volk gewählt. Der Premierminister wird vom
Parlament bestimmt auf Vorschlag des Präsidenten, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und hat der Präsident hat aber trotzdem eine ganze Menge weitere Befugnisse
also ist glaube ich offiziell der Oberbefehlshaber der Armee kann das Parlament
auflösen, hat glaube ich auch noch ein Veto-Recht und gilt auch so ein bisschen als Repräsentant,
während halt der Premierminister so die tägliche,
Politik macht und so für Innenpolitik und Wirtschaft und so weiter relevanter,
ist, stimmt das so in etwa?
Genau, also man kann es aber trotzdem, um Einfahrt halber so ein bisschen das
Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, runterbrechen.
Theoretisch müsste eigentlich schon ähnliche Funktionen oder Aufgaben haben
oder so einen Auftritt haben, wie jetzt ein Bundespräsident,
Bundespräsidentin in Deutschland.
Das heißt auch, es stimmt, also alles, was du gesagt hast, so in die Richtung.
Das heißt, wir haben trotzdem Unterschiede im Vergleich zum deutschen politischen System.
Und zeitgleich wäre es aber schon so, dass eigentlich das, was er macht,
ist nicht das, was er eigentlich, wozu er eigentlich befugt wäre.
Und das ist auch so ein bisschen, so leider schon eine Überleitung zu dem,
was eigentlich gleich kommen wird, weil letzten Endes, da wird immer immer von
Studentinnen genau darauf hingewiesen, dass er eigentlich für gewisse Dinge
gar nicht zuständig ist, für die er sich zu Wort meldet.
Also Vucic hat sozusagen das Amt des Präsidenten auch neu definiert, kann man das so sagen?
Er ist ein Autokrat. Das heißt, an der Stelle, wo einfach Exekutive sprechen
müsste, spricht er. An der Stelle, wo die Judikativi sprechen müsste, spricht er.
An der Stelle, wo die Legislativi sprechen müsste, spricht er.
Er spricht eigentlich immer.
Okay. So, und offensichtlich haben jetzt die Leute in Serbien aber so ein bisschen
die Schnauze voll von diesem Zustand.
Es gab jetzt ein Ereignis im letzten Jahr, was erstmal gar nicht politisch war
sondern da ist ein Dach eingestürzt was ist da passiert?
Ja, es ist tatsächlich sehr politisch.
Ja, aber erst mal nicht, aber dann schon.
Genau, genau. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ein Vordach in Novisat ist eingestürzt
und hat dabei eben, genau, am Bahnhof in Novisat ist ein Vordach eingestürzt.
Das wurde aber frisch eben renoviert und wird auch eben gefeiert und wie toll
das alles ist und wie das Tolles gemacht wurde.
Und Menschen sind natürlich davon ausgegangen, wenn etwas frisch und neu renoviert
ist, dass sie dementsprechend noch mal sicherer und besser und alles als zuvor,
und dann ist eben das Dach eingestürzt, hat in dem Fall auch dann eben Menschen
unter sich begraben das heißt zuerst waren es 15 Menschen die da verstorben sind später.
Einige Monate später ist dann noch mal eine 16.
Person den Folgen erlegen und es sind mittlerweile 16 Verstorbene und einige verletzte.
Und daraufhin gab es eben dann wieder, als das passiert ist,
gab es eben dann wieder Proteste auf der Straße.
Also man wollte einfach wissen, was da los ist, wie kann das sein?
Weil eben das ja alles so neu war.
Und um es nochmal da abzukürzen, letzten Endes gab es circa drei Wochen,
ich glaube sogar ziemlich genau drei Wochen später, gab es von einer Fakultät
in Belgrad, ich würde sie über das darstellen, die Fakultäte der Aschinenkünste übersetzen,
die haben auch so Gedenkminuten abgehalten, das heißt um 11.52 Uhr war dieser
Einsturz des Vordachs und daraus hat sich abgeleitet oder hat sich irgendwann
dann so etabliert über die Wochen,
dass man immer um die Zeit rausgeht und dann eben diese Opfer gedenkt und in
der Regel auch auf der Straße eben die Straßen blockiert und dann eben dann
diese Opfer gedenkt, um auf die Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen für diese Sache,
die einfach da stattgefunden hat.
Und bei diesem Gedenken an diese Opfer in Belgrad,
Von den Studentinnen wurden die dann eben überfallen von Leuten,
wurden also körperlich angegangen, wurden da verschlagen.
Und die haben das dann eben so nicht hingenommen, dass das sein kann,
dass man einfach eben Opfer gedenkt und dementsprechend dann eben angegriffen wird.
Und der Angriff kam von Seiten des Regimes.
Das heißt, man hat da eben auch dann Videos analysiert und rausgefunden,
noch mehr oder weniger, wer da zuständig ist. Man hat dann festgestellt,
dass die Polizei und die Gerichte einfach nicht ihre Arbeit machen.
Das heißt, dass man eigentlich da gar nicht das macht, was man machen müsste
in einem Rechtsstaat, also dem nachgehen.
Und die Leute dementsprechend eben für ihre Taten eben zur Rechenschaft ziehen.
Und dann haben die gesagt, okay, dann haben die einfach die Fakultät blockiert.
Und haben die Fakultät die Blockade ausgesprochen.
Daraufhin wurde das Rektorat, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe,
Universität Belgrad auch nochmal, ging die Blockade.
Und dann relativ schnell so Tag für Tag kamen andere Fakultäten dazu.
Aus Solidarität haben sie dann auch in die Blockade gegangen und das hat dann
irgendwann landesweit sich gestreut.
Und mittlerweile sind über 60 Fakultäten landesweit, ich habe die genauen Zahlen
nicht im Kopf, aber ich weiß, dass man wieder noch neue Fakultäten hinzukommen,
sind im Endeffekt in der Blockade.
Das heißt, die haben die Gebäude einfach dann verriegelt und haben den,
das heißt, es findet kein regulärer.
Kein Hochschulbetrieb statt. Es haben sich Schulen auch dem angeschlossen.
Also auch Schulen sind in die Blockade gegangen.
Und so hat das Ganze im Endeffekt angefangen. Das heißt, es haben die Studentinnen
angefangen, eben dann in die Blockade sich zu organisieren.
Das heißt, die haben angefangen, dann eben Pläne durchzuführen.
Das heißt, die sind einfach zusammengekommen und das Plenum hat gewisse Regeln.
Das heißt, jeder hat einfach zum Beispiel das Recht, einen Vorschlag vorzutragen,
einen Punkt vorzutragen, diskutiert werden soll.
Es gibt dann gewisse Regeln, auch wie gewisse Dinge abgestimmt werden.
Und diese Pläne haben letztendlich dann wiederum einfach alles,
was danach gekommen ist, organisiert und kommuniziert.
Und die haben unter anderem einfach Forderungen gestellt.
Das heißt, am Anfang waren es fünf Forderungen, die sie gestellt haben.
Und diese fünf Forderungen, die sie gestellt haben, waren so völlig banale Sachen eigentlich.
Eigentlich wollten die nur wissen, die wollten offenlegen und Dokumente, Papiere,
des ganzen Vorfalls, also in Verbindung mit dem Vorfall in Nobisar,
dass man einfach danach vollziehen kann, wer ist eigentlich an welcher Stelle,
verantwortlich, was man dementsprechend die Konsequenzen daraus ziehen kann.
Dann wollten sie einfach einfach letzten Endes die Sachen, die sie gefordert
haben, hätten umgesetzt, bedeutet, dass man einen Rechtsstaat hat.
Dass Institutionen das machen, was sie eigentlich machen sollten.
Und diese Forderung haben natürlich einen gewissen Druck ausgelöst.
Das heißt, die haben wiederum dann zu einer gewissen Reaktion bei der Regierung
geführt und natürlich, wie ich es jetzt vorhin gesagt habe,
Vucic spricht ja zu allem, hat sich auch Vucic hier zu Wort gemeldet und erklärt
eben, wie man es sehen kann, hat auch erklärt, dass gewisse Forderungen eben,
wollte ein Gespräch suchen auch mit den Studenten und da haben die tatsächlich
dann die Studenten etwas gemacht, was für ihn ungewöhnlich war.
Und zwar haben die gesagt, du bist nicht zuständig. Und in dem Moment war es
dann schwierig für ihn, irgendwie zu kommunizieren und irgendwas zu handhaben,
weil klar war, egal was er macht, er ist nicht zuständig. Und das haben die
immer wieder wiederholt.
Das heißt, die Medien und alle politischen Akteure haben immer darauf verwiesen,
die Studenten auch immer gefragt, was sie davon halten, was sie davon denken
und so weiter. Und da haben wir Mubicic ins Spiel gebracht.
Und die haben dann wiederholt gesagt, so mantra-mäßig, er ist nicht zuständig.
Und das ist natürlich dann eben mal so eine Machtdynamik.
Und Machtkonstrukt, was über lange, lange Zeit funktioniert hat,
hat es einfach ausgehebelt.
War das richtig so ein Schlachtruf dann so auf den Straßen, dass er nicht zuständig ist?
Es war insofern, es war jetzt kein Schlachtruf, aber es war ein Klassiker bei
allen Interviews, weil die fragen tatsächlich immer wieder viel,
auch von Journalistinnen und die haben immer wieder darauf gewiesen,
er ist nicht zuständig oder auch dieses, wer ist er?
Also nach dem Motto so ein bisschen keine Ahnung, wieso so als er eine Rolle
spielen soll, weil die eine Forderung, die wir hier gestellt haben,
die betrifft im Endeffekt dann, keine Ahnung,
das Ministerium und diese Behörde und die müssen sich darum kümmern.
Es ist deren Aufgabe, das zu tun.
Und mit denen muss man sprechen und nicht mit einer anderen Person.
Okay, also es wurde dann immer wieder mantra-mäßig reingeworfen,
so, was hat der Präsident damit zu tun? Genau.
Und das hat gewirkt, also ich meine, jetzt ist ja so, Studentenproteste,
ist ja meistens der Bevölkerung oft egal.
Weil das ist ja so die Elite und die Studenten protestieren ja sowieso die ganze
Zeit gegen alles mögliche und ich glaube, das wird dann auch so in der Bevölkerung
oft so wahrgenommen mit so, naja, ihr seid ja eh die Privilegierten,
die später die guten Jobs bekommen.
Jetzt regt ihr euch mal wieder was auf, aber das, was irgendwie uns betrifft,
das tangiert ja euch dann auch wieder nicht.
Was haben wir damit zu tun wiederum?
Das, denke ich mal, ist so ein Ding, was man oft so mitbekommt bei allen Protesten.
Aber offensichtlich scheint das jetzt in Serbien so einen gewissen Schritt noch
genommen zu haben, dass es anders wahrgenommen wird.
Ja, weil die Grundvoraussetzungen oder die Rahmenbedingungen andere sind.
Und das, was du beschrieben hast, trifft nicht auf Serbien zu.
Das heißt, es ist eben keine Elite.
Das heißt, für mich ist das ein zentraler Unterschied, den man hier vorheben,
der tatsächlich kaum eine Rolle einnimmt bei der Betrachtung,
ist, dass eben in Serbien hast du noch aus so, ja, wie soll ich sagen.
Überbleibsel aus dem ehemaligen Jugoslawien, diesen Sozialstaat,
der stark ausgeprägt war und eine Geschichte in Serbien ist,
dass 50 Prozent der Studentinnen staatlich gefördert werden.
Das heißt, es können Menschen aus allen Bildungs- und ökonomischen Schichten
studieren. Und das machen die auch.
Das heißt, also Menschen, die aus ASEAM-Verhältnissen kommen,
können mit einem gewissen Durchschnitt und gewissen Noten, können die im Endeffekt
dann über Staatskosten studieren.
Und bekommen auch Unterkünfte und so weiter. Und das macht es dementsprechend
weitaus wenig elitärer als jetzt in Deutschland.
Das heißt, in Deutschland haben wir zum Beispiel eben, da gibt es auch genug
Zahlen dazu, dass einfach hauptsächlich die, die studieren, sind Akademiker-Kinder.
Das heißt, AkademikerInnen, die als Eltern dann behalten, so relativ hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass du auch selber studieren wirst.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt in Serbisch eine andere Nummer. Das spielt tatsächlich
dann insofern eine Rolle, weil die Akzeptanz dessen, was die machen, eine andere ist.
Weil die Kommunikation dessen, die sie haben, ist eine andere ist.
Das heißt, die haben eine völlig andere Verwurzelung.
Und die haben einen völlig anderen Rückhalt auch in der Gesellschaft.
Und dementsprechend werden die auch anders wahrgenommen.
Also es ist vielleicht so, ein zentraler Unterschied, der aus meiner Sicht tatsächlich
eigentlich, den man echt nur streichen muss, glaube ich.
Das andere ist, dass die Studentinnen eben nicht die tollen Jobs bekommen.
Das ist mit so ein Teil von den ganzen Komplexen, was ich versucht habe vorhin so anzudeuten.
Wir haben in Serbien einen unfassbaren Braindrain.
Das heißt, seit vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren gehen Menschen aus Serbien raus,
weil ich so, wie ich es beschrieben habe, die Situation nicht nur ich so eingeordnet
habe, sondern Menschen, die einfach gesagt haben, ich kann hier,
ich sehe hier keine Zukunft.
Das heißt, mit dem Abschluss, den ich gemacht habe, bekomme ich hier eigentlich
keinen vernünftigen Job und ich habe hier auch keine Gesellschaft und keine
Anbedingungen, die ich mir für meine Kinder mir wünsche.
Und dementsprechend hast du einfach unfassbar viele Serbinnen,
die eben im Ausland leben, in der Diaspora.
Und das ist ja auch so, wird dann später vielleicht ein Gespräch nochmal eine
Verbindung, eine Rolle spielen, wenn wir über diese Fahrradtour sprechen.
Das heißt, es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe in einigen.
Interviews oder jetzt auch so Podcasts und sonstige Sachen mir auch angehört,
wie es gab zum Beispiel eine Professorin, die nach Serbien zurückgekehrt ist,
vor einigen Jahren und die jetzt auch so sagt, für sie entsteht es gerade wie so eine Hoffnung von,
Es könnte gelingen, etwas zu bewirken, dass dieser Brain-Brain endet,
dass die Menschen nicht mehr ergehen.
Und viele Studentinnen, auch wir hören ziemlich viele Studenten-Podcasts an, die sagen auch das.
Letzten Endes gehen die auf die Straße und machen das, um nicht das Land verlassen zu müssen.
Das heißt, die wollen eigentlich etwas verändern, um Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen,
in denen sie leben können, in denen sie sich vorstellen können, da zu bleiben.
Und ein zentraler Aspekt ist zum Beispiel auch in dem Wucic-Regime, dass man weiß,
dass es Menschen gibt, die hohe Positionen besetzen ohne akademischen Abschluss,
ohne überhaupt die Kompetenz, die sie mitbringen müssten, beziehungsweise kaufen Diploma.
Man weiß das. Also man weiß das aus Interviews, wo man offensichtlich dann festgestellt
hat, dass Menschen nicht mal benennen konnten, was sie studiert haben oder in
welchem Fach sie was abgeschlossen haben, aber Diploma besitzen zum Beispiel.
Und das sind völlig schräge Nummern.
Und das ist natürlich so ein Punkt, wo die Studentinnen sagen,
ja, was bringt es mir einfach?
Und das ist das, wenn die Leute jetzt sagen, wenn du jetzt nicht studierst,
dann wirst du diese Abschlüsse nicht haben und dann kannst du nicht dein Leben fortsetzen.
Und die sagen halt, das kann ich auch so nicht, Weil was bringt es mir jetzt
in diesem Serbien zu studieren, Abschluss zu machen, weil mein Abschluss sowieso
nichts wert ist, außer ich bin in dieser Partei, Mitglied der Partei und tue
das, was das Regime wünscht.
Dann habe ich im Endeffekt eine Chance, irgendwie eine Stelle zu bekommen und
selbst dann muss ich im Endeffekt gucken, ob es vielleicht doch nicht irgendwie
einen Sohn gibt oder eine Tochter gibt, die im Endeffekt dann die andere Stelle
bekommt, weil sie halt eben der Sohn, der Sohn, die Tochter ist von Person XY.
Und das bedeutet, dass also diese Proteste jetzt eine viel breitere Unterstützung
erfahren haben in der Bevölkerung.
Und wie haben sich jetzt diese Proteste entwickelt, seitdem es sozusagen losging?
Wo sind wir da jetzt?
Also ich würde sagen, es gab, ich würde tatsächlich sagen, das ist ein Gedanke, der mich verfolgt ist,
es ist alles, was jetzt passiert ist, nichts davon ist, glaube ich,
richtig geplant geworden und manches ist geplant geworden.
Das heißt, also manchen Stellen kann man es nicht planen.
Ich glaube, an manchen Stellen sind einfach günstige Faktoren zusammengekommen
und haben dementsprechend Sachen ausgelöst, die wiederum zum nächsten Schritt geführt haben.
Das heißt, ich glaube, dieses Implenum zusammenkommen und diese Blockade hat
zu gewissen Dingen geführt.
Das heißt, Studentinnen haben dann zum Beispiel sich anders kennengelernt und
haben durchs Plenum einfach erfahren, wenn jeder etwas in die Waagschale wirft,
dann kommen eigentlich mit kollektivem Wissen zu richtig guten Entscheidungen
und zu richtig guten Strategien.
Oder haben angefangen, eben dann so zu arbeiten.
Und da gab es erstmal so Demonstrationen, die letzten Endes dann angefangen
haben mit, ich würde sagen, in Slavia gab es eine Demo, die relativ große,
wo auch tatsächlich das so ein bisschen die Runde gemacht hat,
einfach von Emotion her.
Weil es, also ihr habt ja vorhin in diesen Schweigeminuten, habe ich berichtet.
Und wenn man nicht da war und es nicht gesehen hat, erlebt hat,
das ist schwer, eigentlich Worte zu fassen.
Das ist eine unfassbare Kraft, die aus diesem Schweigen hervorgeht.
Das heißt, wenn einfach unfassbar viele Menschen nebeneinander stehen,
in so einer großen Stadt, und niemand bewegt sich, alle stehen da,
alle schweigen, über so einen langen Zeitraum, das ist eine enorme Kraft,
das macht was mit Menschen.
Das sind so Dinge gewesen, die zum Beispiel wiederum wie so einen Dominoeffekt
einen nächsten Schritt bewirkt haben, glaube ich, dass man weiter und weiter
und weiter gegangen ist.
Und dann gab es auch diese Blockade von so einem Knotenpunkt im Bergrad,
wo auch die ersten Mal Studentinnen damit gerechnet haben, dass nur Studenten da hinkommen.
Aber da hat sich die Zivilgesellschaft krass eingeschaltet. Also mich hat mein
Kumpel angerufen mit FaceTime und hat mir einfach dann mit seiner Familie hingegangen
und hat mir gezeigt, wie er da steht.
Und es waren 24 Stunden gegen das ganze Ding. Es war einfach wie so ein Riesenfest,
wie so ein Volksfest letzten Endes.
Und dann gab es eben so auch Sachen, die zum Beispiel diese gemacht haben,
die wiederum auch dann dazu geführt haben, dass dieser Rückhalt der Bevölkerung dann entstanden ist.
Also zum Beispiel neben dieser Autokommander-Geschichte, wo sie diesen Knotenpunkt
blockiert hatten in Belgrad, die haben danach die Straßen gereinigt und geputzt,
die waren sauberer als jemals zuvor.
Und das hat man gesehen und es hat sich herumgesprochen und die Leute,
die gerade fahren herum und sehen das und haben sich gewundert,
was ist denn das jetzt, das sah es noch nie aus so sauber.
Und die haben auch da schon angefangen, eben auch nochmal authentisch und immer
mit jedem Schritt, den sie gemacht haben, ihre Werte, ihre Forderungen,
die sie gestellt haben, auch fortzuleben.
Das wiederum dazu geführt hat, dass Menschen einfach das angesteckt hat,
an gewisser Art und Weise, mit dem, was sie im Prinzip machen.
Auch diese zum Beispiel, wenn man diesen Auslöser nimmt am Anfang,
wo sie in die Blockade gegangen sind, Da haben die ja gesagt.
Sie verurteilen aufs Maximalste jede Form von Gewalt.
Und sie können nicht akzeptieren, das im Land zu leben, wo Gewalt okay ist und
wo Gewalt nicht geahndet wird.
Und auch das haben die jedes Mal aufs Neue immer wieder vorgelebt.
Das heißt, immer wieder gab es Übergriffe von Gewalt.
Das heißt, Menschen wurden im Auto überfahren, Menschen wurden zusammengeschlagen.
Und jedes Mal war die Antwort noch mehr. Noch mehr Menschen auf der Straße.
Noch lauter. Und ehrlich gesagt aber nie die Lebensfreude mit weniger Lebensfreude.
Das heißt, auch das kommt hinzu.
Die jungen Menschen, die auf die Straße gehen, die haben gewisse Botschaften,
die sie mit sich bringen.
Und es ist auch eine gewisse Leichtigkeit, die sie haben, die sie auch da verbreiten
und streuen und die Menschen auch unfassbar ansteckt.
Also wer da hingeht, das ist wie eine Riesenparty letzten Endes.
Und sind einfach Menschen, die unfassbar höflich sind, nett sind,
zuvorkommend sind, solidarisch sind, hilfsbereit und auch das wiederum,
das wirkt sich auf alles drumherum einfach aus.
Jetzt gab es, glaube ich, im März die bisher größte Kundgebung.
Wo war das und wie kam es dazu, dass das sich dann nochmal so,
war das einfach nur eine Konsequenz dadurch, dass immer alles gewachsen ist
oder gab es da nochmal so einen besonderen Moment?
Also ich muss dazu sagen, dieses Wachsen, es ist so hochkomplex.
Es gibt bei den Studentinnen Arbeitsgruppen. Ich habe gesehen,
eine Arbeitsgruppe zum Beispiel ist auch, die beschäftigt sich damit,
mit politischen Akteurinnen zu sprechen und die letztendlich für diese ganze
Geschichte zu gewinnen als Unterstützer.
Das heißt, die führen auch proaktiv Gespräche, ob jetzt mit Gewerkschaften,
mit verschiedenen Gruppierungen.
Das heißt, es ist alles im Zufall überlassen. Ich glaube, dass an verschiedenen
Stellen Dinge einfach dann so sich ergeben und an manchen Stellen wird Geld
sehr gezielt von denen auch dann initiiert und auch geplant.
Also zum Beispiel auch dieses, der ist jetzt den 15. März angesprochen,
der in Belgrad stattgefunden hat.
Davor gab es aber eben genauso große Kundgebungen in anderen Städten,
in anderen studentischen Städten, um auch da wieder ein Zeichen zu setzen.
Es ist das ganze Land, es ist landesweit, um auch zeitgleich solidarisch zu
sein mit allen anderen Universitätsstädten und den Fakultäten und auch den Fokus
darüber zu lenken, zu sehen, was passiert da,
welche Fakultäten sind es da, welche Studenten sind es da, welche Anliegen sind
es da und zeitgleich haben sie auch das in Protestmärch gemacht.
Das heißt, die haben angefangen, aus dem ganzen Land haben sie angefangen,
in diese Städte zu marschieren, also zu laufen.
Das sind mehrere hundert Kilometer an manchen Stellen gewesen.
Das heißt, die haben also auch das zum Beispiel gemacht, um wiederum aus meiner
Sicht strategisch unfassbar klug, du hast natürlich dann über den langen Zeitraum
viel Content, viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Das heißt, du kannst über soziale Netzwerke, die eine sehr große Rolle spielen
in Serbien, kannst du Bilder ausstrahlen, wie Menschen einfach zu Fuß sich auf
den Weg machen in andere Städte, um da eine gemeinsame Kundgebung durchzuführen.
Plus, sie sind bei diesen Protestmärschen durch zig Dörfer gelaufen,
wo sie mit Menschen ins Gespräch gekommen sind. Menschen, die eigentlich nur
Staatsfernsehen haben.
Und die eigentlich nur das hören, was Vucic sagt, weil Vucic einfach jeden Tag
im Fernsehen erscheint und erklärt und einordnet, was eigentlich passiert.
Und das heißt, er hat dann erklärt, dass zum Beispiel die Studentinnen eben
ausländisch bezahlte, gekaufte, inszenierte Gäste sind. Genau, richtig, ja.
Und die Leute haben einfach dann gesehen, hey, die haben sie gesehen vor ihrer
Haustür, konnten mit denen sprechen und haben dann gesehen, das ist nicht so.
Die haben die kennengelernt, ihre Geschichten kennengelernt und dementsprechend
haben auch dann solche Aktionen, die die Studentinnen durchgeführt haben, dazu geführt,
dass wiederum auch in diesen Dörfern, diesen umliegenden Ortschaften einfach
viel mehr Menschen mitbekommen haben, was da eigentlich passiert und dass da
was passiert und welche Dimension es passiert.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass das Fernsehen, das Staatsfernsehen oder im Endeffekt
die ganzen Sender auch wiederum sehr stark in der Hand von Vucic sind.
Das heißt im Endeffekt von Vucic selbst auch. Das heißt, er tritt sehr,
sehr häufig auf, hat unfassbar viele Redezeiten, wo auch in die Kamera spricht und Leuten was erklärt.
Und deswegen war es eben auch ein Anliegen von Studentinnen zu sagen,
wir müssen eigentlich irgendwas machen, um das zu kompensieren oder um die Aufmerksamkeit
zu erreichen und Menschen zu erreichen, die wir sonst nicht erreichen.
Und deswegen war diese Protestmärsche durch das ganze Land ein Element davon zum Beispiel.
Und am Ende war es dann eben so, als man verschiedene Städte so hatte.
Die Proteste wurden immer größer und größer, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, vom Gefühl her.
Das heißt, ich habe das Gefühl, dass immer mehr Menschen da zusammenkommen.
Die Zivilgesellschaft hat sich immer stärker eingestaltet. Also zum Beispiel
auch bei den Protestmärchen in anderen Orten, in anderen Städten.
Was dann so, dass dann Leute ja nicht nur Studentinnen aus Belgrad hingekommen
sind, auch andere Leute aus anderen Ländern, aus anderen Städten sind auch hingefahren
zu den Protesten, um da sich anzuschließen.
Und dann war so die Frage, wo sollen die alle schlafen? Wie kommen die alle unter?
Und dann hat die Zivilgesellschaft angefangen, sich zu organisieren über Facebook-Gruppen.
Ich war in einer zum Beispiel drin, das mir anzuschauen.
Und die haben dann angefangen, eben sich zu organisieren, wer welche Betten
zurecht, die ihnen zur Verfügung stellen kann.
Manche Menschen haben die ganze Wohnung, die ihnen zur Verfügung stellt.
Das heißt, du hast einfach so gemerkt, also da kamen immer mehr und mehr Zivilgesellschaft
stärker ins Spiel rein und dieses, ich bin Teil dieses Ganzen,
was da gerade stattfindet, hat wiederum was bei denen ausgelöst.
Das heißt, es ist eine superkomplexe Entwicklung gewesen, wie so einzelne Schritte,
die sie im Endeffekt erwogen haben, wiederum zu gewissen Phänomenen geführt
haben, dass die Zivilgesellschaft einfach ermöglicht wurde, sich daran zu beteiligen.
Also angefangen mit diesen Protestmärschen, kamen zum Beispiel Omas und Opas
raus, die haben nichts außer Äpfel aus ihrem Garten gepflückt gehabt und haben
die denen einfach gegeben.
Und es war für sie so dieses, ich habe nicht viel, aber das ist das, was ich euch gebe.
Und die haben sich dann so das Gefühl gehabt, auch mitgewirkt zu haben.
Es gab auch ganz viele Bilder, ich muss eigentlich mal weinen,
wenn ich ehrlich bin, die dann entstanden sind und.
Und das ist so das Endeffekt, was dann dazu geführt hat, am 15.
März, also das hat sich so gesteigert, würde ich sagen, an verschiedenen Stellen,
teilweise eben strategisch und eben auch initiiert durch auch verschiedene Solidaritätsproteste.
Also zum Beispiel gab es dann eben auch Proteste auch mit dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr,
solidarische Proteste von Studenten mit denen oder mit den ApothekerInnen oder
PharmazeutInnen oder mit den Landwirten.
Das heißt, man hat verschiedene Gruppierungen auch in gemeinsamen Protestmärchen
organisiert und sich mit denen gemeinsam solidarisiert. und das hat dazu geführt, dass am 15.
März gab es diese riesengroße Demo, in der ich auch war in Belgrad.
Es waren dann, ja, da gibt es verschiedene Zahlen, die im Netz kursieren,
aber ich würde mal sagen, das war dieser Volksaufstand.
So kann man beschreiben, hat ein Kollege, der auch mit da war und Journalist
ist, hat es so beschrieben und ich würde sagen, den Volksaufstand trifft es gar nicht ganz gut.
Mein Zahlen nach, die ich jetzt einordnen würde und ich würde sagen.
Ich würde von mindestens 5.000 bis 600.000 ausgehen ich glaube,
es deutlich mehr waren, aber ich sage mal, wir geben 500.000 bis 600.000 Menschen aus,
dann war es so, Pi mal Daumen, würde ich mal sagen, 10% wahrscheinlich noch
mehr der Bevölkerung, der Gesamtbevölkerung, waren an dem Tag auf der Straße.
Und jetzt kann man überlegen, auf Berlin, jetzt stellen wir mal eine Demo Berlin
vor, mit eben 10% der Gesamtbevölkerung Deutschlands, was das bedeuten würde.
Und dann hast du ein Bild von diesen Massen, die da waren. Also ich war in der
Stadt, du konntest dich nicht bewegen.
Das heißt, überall waren Menschen. Ich bin gestartet im Stadtteil,
der draußen ist und bin dann von da aus reingelaufen.
Und es waren da, also ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, jeder, der irgendwo,
jeder war auf der Straße.
Im Stadtteil, wo ich selbst herkomme, hat mein Onkel mir Bilder geschickt zu
dem Tag an dem Morgen. Und da habe ich auch die Bilder gesehen,
ich habe es auch gepostet über Instagram und so weiter auch.
Da wird mit Drohnen aufgezeichnet.
Jeder, der wohnt, war auf der Straße. Und es haben auch nicht alle aber in die
Stadtmitte geschafft, weil eben es wurden ja auch über Tage davor.
Und die Bahn hieß Brummendrohung, vor die Bahn nicht Busse, ich habe einen Kumpel,
der bei der Busgesellschaft arbeitet, da wurden Busse eingestellt ich wusste
dann eben, wie es abgelaufen ist dass ich eben auch angewiesen wurde wiederum eben,
dass die Busse nicht fahren sollen, reinfahren sollen das heißt,
es wurde wirklich alles getan, um den Menschen zu erschweren,
in die Stadt zu kommen und trotzdem waren so viele Menschen an dem Tag im Endeffekt da,
und jetzt kommt eigentlich der springende Punkt.
Und worüber ich, was ich tatsächlich politisch sehr spannend finde,
es gab an diesem Abend, an dem Tag, gab es einen Vorfall, dass eben ein Gerät
eingesetzt wurde, das jetzt nicht infiziert werden konnte und sagen kann,
was genau für das Gerät war.
Aber es wurde sowas wie eine Art von Waffe eingesetzt, was irgendwelche Töne,
Geräusche, was auch immer, akustische
Wellen ausstößt und dann eben eine Massenpanik, die auslösen sollen.
Ich war tatsächlich auch da, da stand ich tatsächlich an der Terrasse.
Ich habe auch eine Kollegin, die nebenher stand es, gefilmt.
Es waren nämlich am Ende der Schweigeminuten. Das heißt, du hast diese 15 Minuten
Schweigeminuten gehabt an dem Abend.
Und in der letzten, glaube ich, letzten, vollletzten Minute dieser Schweigeminuten ging es dann los.
Und am Anfang habe ich nicht so richtig gecheckt, weil es ist tatsächlich so
bei den Schweigeminuten am Anschluss in den Schweigeminuten kommt immer Lärm.
Und ich dachte so, okay, es ist halt zu Ende und jetzt kommt der Lärm.
Bis ich dann erst, also auf der ersten Millisekunde, glaube ich,
so Gedanken, den ich hatte.
Und dann habe ich gemerkt, die Leute fangen an wegzurennen, es splittet sich
so in zwei Richtungen und rennt auf mich zu. Und dann bin ich auch so weggerannt
und ich dachte, okay, die rennen zu mich drüber.
Und erst so im Laufe der nächsten ein, zwei, drei, vier Tage hat es sich so
rausgestellt mit den Videoaufnahmen, haben, die es einfach so gab,
die es nicht diskussiert haben, hat man so langsam so Puzzleteile gehabt und
konnte sich so ein Bild im Prinzip draus machen.
Und es ist mittlerweile tatsächlich auch eine weitere Forderung.
Das heißt, jetzt sind es nicht mehr fünf Forderungen, es sind mittlerweile sieben Forderungen.
Die sechste Forderung ist tatsächlich die Aufklärung dieses Vorfalls.
Weiß man denn jetzt mittlerweile, was es ist? Also es wurde ja dann erstmal
viel darüber spekuliert.
Ich habe das auch mitbekommen, auch so in Militärkreisen, war das auf einmal
voll die Nachricht mit, was ist da jetzt eingesetzt worden.
Da gab es dann irgendwie so, erste Vermutung war glaube ich so eine Hitzewaffe,
dass man irgendwie so mit so einer Mikrowellenstrahlung sozusagen so einen Hitzeeffekt
macht, aber es war ja eher ein akustisches Ereignis.
Du hast es nicht gehört, du hast es nicht empfunden.
Ich habe tatsächlich, das Problem ist, ich habe schon was zum Ton gehört,
aber ich habe es nicht bewusst wahrgenommen. Das war eher was Unbewusstes.
Also tatsächlich meine unbewusste Reaktion war, ich hatte, an meinem Hirn ging
das Bild an, da fährt ein Auto rein.
Das war mein Bild. Weil auch es war in Kombination mit Ton und dem Menschen
auf die Seite gesprungen sind.
Und man muss dazu sagen, was jetzt auch nicht gesagt wird, ist am Morgen an
diesem Tag ist auch wieder ein Auto in Menschen reingefahren.
Das heißt, es gibt tatsächlich eine gängige Methode, die seit vielen Monaten
genutzt wird von Seiten des Regimes, ist, dass einfach immer wieder Menschen
mit Autos in Menschen reinfahren.
Und man hat versucht, einfach Menschen so einzuschüchtern. Im Endeffekt,
das ist Terror, das ist nichts anderes als Terror, reiner Terror.
Das heißt, die Studentinnen haben tatsächlich im Vorfeld immer gebeten,
dass an dem Tag bitte alle in die Stadt kommen und alle.
Zeigen, wofür sie eigentlich einstehen. Und sie haben immer darum gebeten,
dass bitte Familien, auch da alle mit Familien reinkommen.
Auch das hat strategische Gründe gehabt. Jetzt nicht nur im Sinne von,
wir zeigen, dass ganz Serbien im Endeffekt hinter diesen Forderungen steht,
sondern letzten Endes auch insofern Gründe, wenn Kinder auf der Straße sind,
darf zum Beispiel die Polizei kein Trängas einsetzen.
Also das heißt, es gab wirklich so verschiedenste Aspekte im Hintergrund,
die diskutiert wurden, die unter anderem auch dann so kommuniziert wurden,
weil klar war, bitte kommt auch mit Familienkindern dahin.
Und ich muss sagen, als ich morgens aufgestanden bin, an dem 15.,
da kursierte gerade das Video, wo eben Leute losgelaufen sind und wieder ein
Auto reingefahren ist in Menschen.
Und da dachte ich, scheiße, ja, mal gucken, wie viele Menschen zu Hause bleiben
oder wie viele Familien sich doch entscheiden, mit den Kindern nicht hinzukommen.
Und als ich dann eben raus bin und dann gesehen habe, ganz viele Kinder,
ganz viele Familien mit Kinderwägen und so weiter, dann wusste ich,
okay, die werden trotzdem hingehen.
Und deswegen ist auch, glaube ich, auch in Verbindung mit den Erfahrungen der letzten Monate,
ich glaube auch, dass das auch mit Teileffekt war, der Reaktion und auch des
Empfindens der Leute, weil natürlich du abgespeichert hast im Hinterkopf,
eine Methode angewandt wird, dass Menschen ein Auto hier reinfahren in uns.
Und dementsprechend regierst du auch automatisch dann wahrscheinlich mit diesem
Wissen, was du abgespeichert hast.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Also es ist, glaube ich, immer noch ein bisschen ungeklärt.
Die Vermutung lag so bei so Schallwaffen.
Das aktuellste, interessanteste Piece in der ganzen Geschichte ist,
dass es eine Untersuchung gab von russischer Seite aus,
die auch eine völlig schräge Nummer, wo auch die Studentinnen sagen würden,
die sind nicht zuständig.
Also es ist nicht der ausländische Geheimdienst hier oder von Russen oder Amerikanern,
wer auch immer, ist nicht zuständig für diese Sachen.
Wir haben eigene Institutionen, eigene Behörden, die diese Arbeit leisten müssten.
Und das Witzige ist an dem Papier, was von dem russischen Papier veröffentlicht
wurde, was irgendwo gesagt wurde, dass eben da nichts zum Einsatz kam,
wurde jetzt aufgedeckt von Leuten im Netz, dass da eben Buchstaben vorkommen,
die es den russischen gar nicht gibt.
Es ist ein serbischer Buchstabe, es ist hier und das haben die gar nicht und
zeitgleich wurde auch Metadaten entdeckt, dass es auf Word geschrieben wurde,
was im Russland nicht verwendet wird.
Das heißt, es gibt einige Indizien, Indikatoren, die darauf hindeuten,
dass das Dokument gefälscht ist und tatsächlich überhaupt bearbeitet wurde und
tatsächlich gar nicht von den Russen stammt.
Und das ist aber auch jetzt etwas, was so ein bisschen so an der Seite so mitschwingt.
Also ich bin in verschiedenen Foren mit drin und gucke immer so,
was auf Entwicklungen da sind.
Das ist aktuell so eine Geschichte, die jedenfalls gerade kursiert.
So, 10% der Bevölkerung gehen auf die Straße.
Ich glaube, allein 300.000, also mal gut die Hälfte von dieser Zahl, waren dann in Belgrad.
Also sozusagen 5% der Bevölkerung auf der Straße.
Ich rede von Belgrad. Ich hätte tatsächlich, diese 300.000 ist die Zahl für
Belgrad kursiert, aber ich meine wirklich, dass 500.000, 600.000 waren.
Im Belgrad wird es sogar viel mehr.
Also das Problem ist einfach, du musst überlegen, die haben halt Leute gezählt
an gewissen Punkten. Und an gewissen Punkten nicht. Die Stadt ist groß.
Das heißt, Leute sind in Stadtteilen auf die Straße und sind gar nicht bis zur
Stadt mitgekommen zum Beispiel. Die werden ja gar nicht gezählt.
Deswegen gibt es auch tatsächlich niemanden, der bis heute seriös eine Zahl
rausgeben kann. Du kannst es tatsächlich nicht rausgeben.
Also aus dem Stadt, wo ich gekommen bin zum Beispiel, da gibt es eine Brücke,
über die Brücke durfte nur ein gewisser Teil rübergehen, damit die Brücke nicht
durch die Schwimmbewegungen einstürzt.
Und das heißt, ich weiß, am Abend um 18 Uhr saß ich in einem Restaurant,
hab gegessen, hab die im Fernsehübertragung gesehen, wie Leute immer noch in
der Brücke stehen und nicht rübergekommen sind.
Das heißt, deswegen ist die Zahl schwer zu fassen. Und vielleicht ein Punkt
noch an der Stelle, dem 15.
Es wurde gezielt, es gibt jemanden vom Parlament, den Pionierpark,
den hat Vucic über Wochen davor, hat er Leute Zelte aufstellen lassen und es
waren dann die Studentinnen, die lernen wollen.
Also, das war der sie genannt und hat dann angefangen, eben so gegen Studentinnen
irgendwie da zu engagieren.
Und ich weiß, dass zum Beispiel teilweise sind die Studentinnen drin.
Aber teilweise Studenten von Fakultäten, die gar nicht in der Blockade sind,
das heißt, die könnten eigentlich wunderbar studieren gehen,
also keiner hindert sie dran.
Teilweise waren es auch gecasterte Leute. Und das weiß ich, weil ich wiederum
einen Kumpel habe, der eben so Castingsachen macht, also für Werbung,
für Unternehmen und der wurde auch angerufen und gefragt, Gruppe Leute hätte,
die für den Betrag in den Park gehen zum Beispiel.
Also, das heißt, ich weiß aus sicherer Quelle, dass das einfach gekaufte Leute im Endeffekt waren.
Und wenn du hingegangen bist, hast du gemerkt, da waren auch Leute mit dabei,
die auch deutlich älter waren, wusste, sind keine Studenten.
Irgendwann haben sie angefangen, Traktoren dahin zu stellen drumherum und im
Endeffekt hat sich so ein Ding entwickelt und in den Park waren am Schluss irgendwelche
Schläger-Truppen drin einfach.
Und die These war einfach die, also mit dem Wissen, was ich habe und den Menschen,
den ich gesprochen habe, deutet viel darauf hin, dass Vucic an dem Tag wollte die Eskalation haben.
Das heißt, dieser Paar hat eigentlich die Funktion gehabt, zum einen die Funktion,
glaube ich, er hat es gekommuniziert, dass sie ihn schützen sollen,
die Leute, wenn Leute ins Parlament stürmen.
Er hat immer gesagt, das Parlament wird gestürmt werden und er möchte einfach
Leute haben, die ihn schützen, so nach dem Motto.
Aber letzten Endes ist meine These und vieles deutet darauf hin,
der wollte die Eskalation haben, eine Gewalteskalation haben.
Und letzten Endes standen tatsächlich in der Straße quergenüber,
gab es auch schon eine Spezialeinheit der Polizei, die da stand,
relativ früh und gewartet hat. Ich weiß nicht, worauf sie gewartet hat, ich stand aber da.
Davon sind Bilder auch dann da. Und ich weiß auch, dass tatsächlich immer wieder
eben aus dem Rhein daraus Leute zu provozieren.
Und geplant war am Anfang von den Studentinnen, dass die Bühne uns was geben
soll oder zumindest irgendwie ein Teil von der Sprache und Ansprache sollte
vor dem Parlament stattfinden.
Irgendwann ist es dann doch aber nicht am Parlament gewesen,
sondern man hat es dann Richtung Slavia runter verlagert.
Das heißt, die lagert sich da entspannt da vorm Parlament. Und es war etwas,
was zum Beispiel für die jetzt nicht so angenehm war.
Das heißt, eigentlich wollten die da die gedrängte Massen haben und dass da
eben dann sowas kommen kann.
Man muss dazu sagen, am ganzen Tag habe ich keine Polizei gesehen.
Das heißt, bei jeder kleinen Demo in Freiburg, egal wo, hast du Polizisten drumherum,
in Serbien eigentlich auch, die einfach gucken, dass einfach Sachen ihren Wegen
gehen und eben auch dann Schutz da gewährleistet wird.
Die gab es da nicht. Das heißt, ich würde behaupten an der Stelle wiederum,
dass die Eskalation, dass die gewünscht war.
Und das ist der springende Punkt. Die Studenten haben vorab,
finde ich, sehr klug kommuniziert.
Die haben im Endeffekt darauf hingewiesen, auf das Problem, das es da gibt mit
dem Park, mit den Provokateuren und darauf hingewiesen, wer zuständig ist und
was gemacht werden muss.
Und haben zeitgleich auch gesagt, in dem Moment, wo etwas passiert,
was irgendeine Form von Gewalt beinhaltet, werden wir unsere Westen ablegen.
Wir haben so grelle Westen an immer.
Und dann ist die Demonstration, die Kundgebung aufgelöst im Moment.
Und als diese Geschichte war mit dieser Waffe, wer es auch immer,
und da gab es aus dem Park heraus auch gewisse Sachen, die geflogen sind und
so weiter, haben die ihre Westen abgelegt und haben die Kundgebung aufgelöst.
Und eigentlich ist das tatsächlich der springende Punkt, was mich wiederum so
ein bisschen ärgere auf der einen Seite, dieses Gespräch über diese Waffe.
Hat am Anfang, glaube ich, Vucic geschadet und ab einem gewissen Punkt wollte
er, glaube ich, das sogar haben.
Weil letzten Endes hat dann die ganze Energie, Ressource floss in das hinein,
herauszufinden, was es überhaupt war.
Und eigentlich ist es untergegangen, was eigentlich stattgefunden hat.
Es hat etwas Historisches stattgefunden. Das heißt, es gab eine unfassbar große,
einzigartige Menschenmenge auf den Straßen, die friedlich demonstriert hat und
die friedlich nach Hause gelaufen ist, als die Kundgebung dann aufgelöst wurde.
Und das ist etwas, das ihn gestört hat und stört, weil es einfach zeigt,
dass eben nicht das Bild ist, was er gezeichnet hat.
Also von diesen gewaltsamen Menschen, die stürmen und das und das.
Da zeigt man ein Bild im Fernsehen von den jungen Menschen, von der ganzen Demo,
von den ganzen Menschen, die auf die Straße gehen, was völlig entgegengesetzt
ist, was eigentlich tatsächlich da stattfindet.
Und deswegen hat es mich so ein bisschen geärgert, dass eigentlich dann der
Kernpunkt, das erreicht wurde von den Studentinnen, so eine riesige,
gewaltige Menschstimmung auf die Straße zu bekommen und zeitgleich durch ihre
Werte, die sie über Monate vorgelebt haben,
hinzubekommen, dass Menschen auch wiederum friedlich nach Hause laufen, das ist was Enormes.
Verstehe.
Wie ist denn jetzt so, ich meine, die Proteste halten jetzt schon seit fünf
Monaten an, das ist ja schon krass und sind auch regelmäßig,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, also täglich, wöchentlich oder wie läuft das?
Täglich, landesweit.
Ähm, bewirkt es etwas?
Also ich meine, wann sind die nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlen?
Es ist eigentlich egal, also die Wahlen sind nicht völlig egal.
Also am aktuellen Zeitpunkt ist tatsächlich eher so, also solange du einfach
nicht frei Wahlen hast, sind die Wahlen eigentlich völlig schnurz.
Und es hat tatsächlich, also ich würde sagen, der 15. ist insofern ausschlaggebend,
weil manche haben im Vorfeld kommuniziert, dass es die Idee ist.
Und da wird dann eben das passieren und da wird dann irgendwie,
uns wurden gewisse Erwartungen reingelegt. Und die Studenten haben sehr stark
versucht zu kommunizieren, zu sagen, bitte, dieser 15.
Ist nicht das, wenn man sagt, jetzt drücke ich einen Knopf und dann wachen wir
am nächsten Tag auf und haben die Demokratie. So läuft das nicht.
Und ich glaube aber, dass trotzdem, obwohl die Leute es irgendwann wussten,
eine Erwartung da war, dass vielleicht dann aufgrund dieser Masse,
also noch einmal, wenn man sagt, über 10% der Bevölkerung des Landes steht auf
der Straße in einer Stadt.
Dann ist das eigentlich so eine klare Botschaft.
Und dass dann gar keine Reaktion weiterhin kommt.
Und im Gegenteil, man ist weiter ignoriert. Und dann mit einer Gegendemo,
ja, der hat eine Gegendemo ankündigt gehabt, ist eine andere Baustelle.
Die dann noch größer und noch besser werden soll was ein absoluter Flop war.
Und letzten Endes war die Erwartung bei den Leuten glaube ich schon,
dass etwas jetzt sich ändert und dann war glaube ich schon erstmal so für mich
war es wie so ein Lackmustest wie wird jetzt die Bevölkerung damit umgehen?
Wird es im Endeffekt jetzt dieses Gefühl geben von ja, jetzt ändert sich halt
doch nichts also dieser Defettismus, der sowieso über Jahrzehnte gepflegt und
gehegt wird oder bleibt man am Ball?
Und meiner Beobachtung nach würde ich sagen, dass eher so eine Trotzgeschichte daraus entstanden ist.
Das heißt, die Studenten haben im Vorfeld kommuniziert, weil immer gefragt wurde,
das ist der nächste Schritt.
Und haben Studenten gesagt, der nächste Schritt ist, dass die Zivilgesellschaft
einfach stärker einschreitet und die sich einfach organisiert.
Das heißt, so wie wir, müssen die auch sich organisieren.
Und haben dann einfach verwiesen, dass jetzt zum Beispiel laut Recht und laut
Strukturen gibt es eben sowas wie Bürger in Versammlungen,
die eigentlich stattfinden könnten und wo Bürger kommunal und in Stadtgebieten,
Stadtteilen, also auch Belgien zum Beispiel verschiedene Bezirke aufgeteilt,
die auch eben so teilweise in gewissen Bereichen autonom, also bürokratisch
ablaufen und das sich darüber organisiert und da gewisse Dinge einfach dann vorantreibt.
Und diese Idee wurde aufgegriffen. Das heißt, es haben sich danach auf einmal,
es war davor, war es eher so dieses, ah ja, was sollen wir, wie sollen wir das
machen und wie soll das gehen?
Und auf einmal habe ich gemerkt, so gesehen, überall poppen diese Bürgerversammlungen
auf. Das heißt, es haben sich Leute im Freien getroffen, in Hallen getroffen,
die haben über einen Messenger-Dienst getroffen.
Den ich eine lange Zeit vor meinem Handy gelöscht habe, installieren musste,
genutzt wird, Viber heißt er, der datenschutztechnisch volle Katastrophe ist.
Haben die Gruppen gegründet.
Mein Stadtteil zum Beispiel hat eine Gruppe von 200.000 Menschen drin,
die sich nicht kennen, die sich darüber organisieren.
Und da tatsächlich eben sich wöchentlich,
glaube ich, zwischen Zyklen sich treffen und Dinge beschließen.
Und tatsächlich auch das zum Beispiel jetzt auch verankern wollen, auch institutionell.
Das heißt, die wollen auch dann das, was sie machen wollen, im Endeffekt überführen
in Strukturen, die dann darüber hinaus einfach dann wirksam sind.
Die wollen auch gewisse Entscheidungsbefugnisse mitbekommen,
einfach kommunal in ihren Stadtteilen und so weiter.
Das heißt, das ist tatsächlich etwas, was sich sehr stark entwickelt hat danach.
Und es hat sich eine Sache entwickelt, und zwar, ich habe dann beobachtet,
dass egal wo ein Stand von der Partei, der gegehenden Partei aufgebaut wurde,
hat sich die Zivilgesellschaft formiert.
Das heißt, der offene Widerstand ist viel deutlich spürbarer und sichtbarer.
Das heißt, letzten Endes, was ich so mitbekommen habe von den Aussagen der Leute,
war immer dieses ich werde es nicht mehr zulassen, dass du hier frei atmen kannst.
Das heißt, egal wo du auftrittst, wirst du uns spüren.
Und das heißt, egal in welchem Dorf, egal in welchen, in den kleinsten Gemeinden,
egal wo die stehen, wo die aufbauen, stehen Menschen da und pfeifen,
mit den Triller pfeifen und lassen die nicht sprechen und teilweise wurden sie
mit Eiern auch beworfen und so weiter.
Das heißt, also das ist nach dem Motto, wir lassen nicht mehr zu,
dass für dich der Alltag einkehrt, den du scheinbar konstruierst.
Für uns gibt es keinen Alltag. Für uns geht der Alltag nicht weiter.
Es gibt kein Zurück mehr. Und es ist etwas, was sich tatsächlich verändert hat.
Und deswegen ist es auch spannend, eben zu gucken, was ist der nächste Schritt,
wie geht es im Endeffekt da weiter.
Aber es ist schon so, dass die Vigegesellschaft sich sehr, sehr stark eingeschaltet hat.
Und jetzt ist aktuell eine große Sache, die im Endeffekt von den Studentinnen
gerade strategisch eben auch entschieden wurde, ist, das Fernsehen zu blockieren.
Das heißt, ich habe am Anfang gesagt, dass eben Fernsehen, der sehr starken
Stellenwert hat in den ganzen Kosmos, in der ganzen Dynamik,
weil eben halt darüber der Präsident sehr viel Redezeit hat und sehr viel sich
Menschen interessieren kann,
vor allem auch ältere Menschen und Menschen auf dem Land und einfach dann das.
Meinungsmonopol hat und im Endeffekt das Narrativ bestimmt.
Und jetzt haben die dieses öffentlichen Rundfunk, rechtlichen Rundfunk,
wie hier übersetzt ins Deutsche, haben die im Endeffekt die Gebäude blockiert
und haben tatsächlich eben versucht
zu verhindern, dass Menschen da reinkommen und ihre Arbeit zu tun.
Und am Anfang war auch da wieder, gab es ein bisschen gewaltsame Ausschreitungen, ein bisschen.
Also das heißt, es gibt gewaltsame Ausschreitungen, aber die Polizei ist da
auch ein bisschen rein, hat versucht irgendwie zu machen, aber so richtig eskaliert ist es nicht.
Und mittlerweile ist es seit einer Woche, sind diese Gebäude blockiert.
Seit einer Woche fällt die Tagesschau spontan dazu, regelmäßig aus oder ich
weiß nicht richtig, oder nur teilweise wird es ausgestrahlt oder irgendwie auch
so komisch ausgestrahlt.
Das heißt, etwas ist außer Kraft gesetzt und deren Forderung ist wiederum, die fordern wieder,
den Selder abzuschalten, solange die Institutionen nicht funktionieren,
weil es gibt nämlich eine Behörde, die vor knapp 20 Jahren oder über 20 Jahren gegründet wurde,
RRM heißt die, die eigentlich den Auftrag hat, die Aufgabe hat,
Medien zu regulieren und nachzuprüfen, inwiefern Desinformationen zum Beispiel gestreut werden.
Oder wenn gewisse Zeitungen oder Fernsehen, wie auch immer, gewisse Dinge,
Gesetze oder Sachen überschreiten, dass sie dementsprechend einfach dann entweder
die Lizenzen abnehmen oder sonstige Strafen zahlen müssen.
Und dieses Ding wurde, ist tatsächlich letztes Jahr ausgelaufen,
Ende letzten Jahres und wurde nicht neu zusammengesetzt.
Das heißt, es gibt das gar nicht aktuell.
Und jetzt kannst du dir ja vorstellen, dass natürlich im Zuge der Proteste,
der Städtisch-Proteste eben viele Überschreitungen stattfinden,
aber halt niemand das reguliert und deswegen sagen die, pass auf,
wir blockieren diese ganze Geschichte hier, bis einfach diese Behörde zusammengesetzt
wurde und ihre Aufgabe übernimmt, ihre Funktion übernimmt und wir überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben,
ein staatliches Fernsehen zu haben, was dementsprechend keine Lügen verbreitet,
sondern einfach ihren Job macht, den sie machen müssten.
Mhm.
Das heißt, wenn ich deine Schilderung so zusammenfasse,
die Proteste haben derzeit eigentlich noch gar nicht an Intensität verloren,
sondern bleiben gleich oder nehmen in gewisser Hinsicht sogar zu,
weil sie jetzt sozusagen auch neue Kampforte ausgemacht haben. Kann man das so sehen?
Das Problem ist ich versuche echt relativ viel so mitzulesen und mitzubekommen,
es gibt so x verschiedene Bestrebungen, Bewegungen und Perspektiven,
die man eigentlich berücksichtigen kann und muss, also zum Beispiel,
der Druck ist natürlich schon auch groß, also zum Beispiel nehmen wir jetzt
die Schulen raus, so die ganzen Bildungsbereiche Lehrkräften wurden Gehälter
nicht gezahlt das heißt, es sind Lehrkräfte, also LehrerInnen,
die einfach Familien haben und da gab es zum Beispiel auch da wiederum aus dem
IT-Sektor Gruppen, die zum Beispiel,
Webseiten aufgesetzt haben, wo man spenden kann.
Und wiederum diese Spenden an den Lehrkräften zukommen zu lassen,
damit sie einfach das ein bisschen kompensieren können. Das heißt,
du merkst schon, es gibt schon an gewissen Stellen so einen Druck, der einfach groß ist.
Auch Schulen, die zum Beispiel das Blockade rausnehmen, als sie gesagt haben,
wir wollen einfach diesen Druck für die Lehrkräfte nicht mehr haben.
Das heißt, wir machen unsere Blockade auf eine andere Art und Weise zum Beispiel.
Es ist wirklich sehr komplex. Du merkst schon, dass einfach jeder Monat für
Monat schon Ressourcen kostet. Und dementsprechend ist ein Druck schon da.
Und auch diese Frage immer, die auch, glaube ich, immer schon laut ist.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Weil irgendwie muss es ja irgendwie jetzt anders, irgendwas muss jetzt passieren.
Das heißt, er ignoriert es jetzt weiter.
Zeitgleich sehe ich aber auch wiederum einen Druck auf der Seite des Präsidenten.
Das heißt, auch er ist massiv. Also da merkst du, dass er einfach intern ganz stark bröckelt.
Also angefangen, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, eine Gino-Demo ausgerufen hatte,
die hätte Ende März stattfinden sollen. Der hat dann irgendwann verschoben.
Mein erster Gedanke war, zu verschoben, weil er gemerkt hat,
irgendwas passt nicht mehr. Er kriegt die Leute nicht mehr zusammen.
Deswegen hat es verschoben. Und so war es ja auch dann.
Das heißt, es hat jetzt dann im 12. April das Wochenende stattgefunden,
war das am Sonntag und hat auch wiederum eben so die ganze Straße sperren lassen,
hat Autos abschleppen lassen.
Rechtswidrig. Also völlig irre. Und hat dann aus dem ganzen Land,
hat er Leute zusammengekrabten.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ein Kumpel bei einem Busunternehmen oder der beim Bus,
nicht Unternehmen, sondern bei der städtischen Busgesellschaft arbeitet,
der konnte mir die ganzen Zahlen nennen, da wird die ganzen Einblicke genannt,
da wurden einfach x städtische Busse, Buslinien auch, wurden einfach ausgesetzt,
die fuhren nicht mehr und die wurden eingesetzt, um Menschen aus ganz Serbien
nach Belgrad zu kutschieren.
Und die bezahlt wurden auch wiederum. Auch da weiß man, dass sie Summen haben,
dass sie Geld bekommen haben, um dahin zu kommen.
Und er wollte, letztendlich wollte er Folgendes machen, er wollte ein Bild konstruieren
von einer Masse, um Legitimität zu bekommen für das, was er macht.
Weil er ist aktuell, ist das, was er macht, legal. Er hat zum Beispiel eine
neue Regierung zusammengekloppt,
Weil er eben halt sagt, ja, ich brauche jetzt eine neue Regierung.
Und jetzt macht er, egal, als Präsident, macht er eine neue Regierung.
Also jetzt wird sich, ich weiß nicht, einen neuen Minister irgendwie ausgerufen.
Und das ist alles legal. Aber zeitgleich merkt er, was er macht, ist nicht mehr legitim.
Weil er einfach merkt, dass ihm seit dem Spätes nach 15 klar ist,
die Masse steht nicht dahinter.
Und jetzt wollte er eigentlich ein Bild generieren, um zeigen zu können,
dass er es nicht mache, ist legitim. Aber ist es eben nicht.
Und deswegen flippt er, glaube ich, auch so richtig aus.
Das heißt, sein Protest, den er geplant hatte, war ein völliger Flop.
Das heißt, ich glaube, da waren um die 50.000 Menschen oder sowas da.
Und es waren auch, du hast doch Bilder, wie Leute gehen, während er spricht
und die aber nicht gehen dürfen, weil die von Ordnung festgehalten werden und
nur immer ein paar Leute rausgelassen werden.
Du hast doch gesehen, was für Leute da waren. Du hast doch gesehen,
die Plastikstühle haben die mitgenommen zum Beispiel und so weiter.
Es war eine komische Szene, die dabei sich abgespielt haben.
Und deswegen merkst du wiederum bei ihm auch dieser Rückhalt bröckelt und auch,
glaube ich, bei ihm schon auch ein Druck da ist.
Und darum ist tatsächlich schon der, also ich kann es jetzt nicht beurteilen,
es ist, glaube ich, schwierig zu fassen, was jetzt in ein, zwei,
drei, vier Wochen sein wird.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass von Seiten der Studentinnen und von Teilen der Zivilgesellschaft,
von großen Teilen der Zivilgesellschaft, also die Option, zurück zum Alten, die ist nicht da.
Und die Studentinnen werden definitiv nicht aufhören, bevor ihre Forderungen erfüllt werden.
Jetzt hast du hast du abgetan mit den Wahlen?
Also ich glaube, regulär sind die Wahlen erst in drei Jahren wieder oder zwei Jahren, genau.
22 war das jetzt, also in zwei Jahren wäre theoretisch Wahl,
aber du hast ja wenig Hoffnung, dass jetzt über Wahlen selber was geregelt werden kann.
Was weiß man denn über potenzielle Wahlmanipulationen?
Also die Wahlen waren es eigentlich nicht frei vorher. Das heißt,
du hast natürlich eben Leute gehabt, die teilweise gewählt haben,
die eigentlich gestorben waren.
Du hast Leute gehabt, die aus Bosnien reingekartet wurden, die um da zu wählen.
Du hast Leute gehabt, die einfach vor Wahllokalen eingeschüchtert werden.
Das heißt, die einfach Fotos machen mussten und zeigen mussten, wie sie gewählt haben.
Also, das heißt, du hast einfach, Freiewahlen gab es nicht.
Und dementsprechend ist so dieses, wenn jetzt, aber jetzt will auch keiner Wahlen haben.
Also es war natürlich auch eine Debatte, dass im Juni vielleicht nochmal neue
Wahlen geben soll und so weiter, aber eigentlich möchte die keiner haben.
Auch die Obstitution letztendlich auch nicht.
Das heißt, letztendlich ist es einfach nicht klar. Also man muss dazu sagen,
in dem Moment, wo die Studenten sagen würden, die unterstützen wir,
würden die halt sowas von gewinnen.
Das heißt, es wäre einfach ein krasses Wahlergebnis. Also letzten Endes braucht
es wahrscheinlich schon eine politische Kraft, die irgendwie es übersetzt,
weil die Studenten aber ganz klar sagen, wir werden nicht Politik machen.
Das heißt, wir wollen auch gar nicht Politik machen.
Letztendlich, was die studentischen Forderungen sind, was die Studenten immer
fordern, was immer missverstanden wird, ist, alles, was sie machen und alles, was sie fordern, ist,
Wir wollen einen Rechtsstaat. Wir wollen das, was wir haben an Strukturen und
Prozessen und Gesetzen, dass das eingehalten wird.
Und wenn das alles eingehalten wird, sind wir damit eigentlich schon völlig fein.
Das heißt, deswegen ist zum Beispiel auch diese Geschichte, diese Tour,
die sie gemacht haben nach Straßburg, die wurde auch völlig an einigen Stellen
missverstanden, dass sie im Endeffekt darum bitten, die EU bitten,
dass sie unterstützt werden.
Das war nicht der Punkt. Die haben nur geschaut, wiederum in ihrer analytischen
Art und Weise, wie sie es einfach machen, und geschaut, wer ist für welche Bereiche zuständig.
Und die haben gesehen, okay, es gibt einfach da den Europäischen Rat und es
gibt einfach dann im Prinzip eben auch einmal eine Institution, wo Serbien einfach.
Mitglied ist, die einfach für Menschenrechte und solche Sachen zuständig ist
und deswegen wenden wir uns an die Institution, die dafür zuständig ist.
Das heißt, diese Zuständigkeit, wer ist zuständig, ist das, was eigentlich Sie
immer sehr stark das prägt und diktiert und erkommt all dem, was sie tun.
Und genauso die Gespräche mit der EU, aber dann wiederum auch die Zuständigkeit
im Sinne von auch in Bezug auf diese Beschlüsse, was dieses Lithium angeht.
Es gibt nämlich ein Projekt und da geht es um Lithiumabbau im Jadartal und da,
gibt es auch mit, Deutschland ist tatsächlich mit drin, stark im Prozess,
gab es auch Treffen mit Olaf Scholz und irgendwelche Abkommen und die wollen
eigentlich das zum Beispiel wieder zur Debatte machen, dass man da,
weil die einfach sagen, dass da wiederum auch Dinge, die beschlossen wurden
und die Verträge, die geschlossen wurden, auch wiederum nicht sauber waren,
nicht korrekt waren und die Institutionen ihre Aufgabe nicht erfüllt haben.
Und letztendlich suchen sie wiederum auch da, würde ich sagen,
GesprächspartnerInnen, die dafür zuständig sind, um da Prozesse zu haben,
die eigentlich legal, legitim und so ablaufen, wie sie eigentlich sein sollten.
Weil eben gewisse Prüfverfahren, gewisse Sachen eigentlich gar nicht gemacht
wurden, die im Vorfeld gemacht werden müssen.
Ja, das ist so ein Abkommen, was das letztes Jahr im Juli gemacht wurde.
Offensichtlich gibt es dort größere Lithium-Vorkommen und ist natürlich derzeit
ein sehr gefragter Stoff im Hinblick auf Batteriebau etc. Ja.
Jetzt, wo du schon auch die EU ins Spiel gebracht hast, was ist denn so dein Eindruck,
wie sehr geht der Blick der serbischen Bevölkerung ins Ausland?
Also gibt es da Erwartungshaltungen, gibt es da Forderungen,
gibt es da überhaupt eine Hoffnung, dass es in irgendeiner Form von Unterstützung
von außen geben kann und damit so ein bisschen verbunden,
wie schätzt du überhaupt das Verhältnis der Serben zu Europa und speziell auch zur EU ein?
Also es gibt natürlich verschiedene Umfragen, die durchgeführt wurden mal.
Und da war es so, glaube ich, so 50-50 mehr oder weniger.
Von der Bevölkerung her leicht mit mehr gegen als mehr dafür.
Leicht mehr gegen als mehr dafür zum EU-Beitritt. Aber auch zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo ich sagen würde, Es gab einfach nie sowas, also die Überlegungen, in die EU beizutreten,
basieren immer auf der Überlegung nach dem, wie der Wutsch sich das vorstellt.
Das heißt, wir haben ja vorhin so erzählt, wie Autokraten denken und funktionieren.
Und die Überlegung natürlich, also die Prämisse, in die EU beizutreten,
ist ja eher so, nach Wutschits-Logik, wir geben einfach das,
also im Endeffekt schöpfen wir einfach unser Land aus und verkaufen einfach
alles, was irgendwie wertvoll ist.
Und unabhängig dessen, was es für die Bevölkerung, für das Land bedeutet.
Und Land war nicht wirklich jetzt auch für den Boden oder für die Natur und Umwelt.
Und das sind natürlich eine Bedingung, glaube ich, die Leute nicht so cool und attraktiv finden.
Und deswegen ist, glaube ich, wäre tatsächlich die Frage, wenn man so eine Umfrage.
Durchführen müsste oder wollte, müsste man, glaube ich, schon erstmal einen
Weg definieren, der so wäre, dass einfach ein EU-Beitritt auf Augenhöhe geschieht.
Das heißt, wo einfach dann die Werte, die EU sich selbst auf die Fahnen geschrieben
hat, auch eingehalten werden.
Und das ist tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen jetzt gerade die Debatte.
Das heißt, man schaut natürlich jetzt schon drauf, Man sieht,
dass hier einfach seit fünf Monaten einfach eine sehr demokratische,
basisdemokratische, zivilgesellschaftlich getragene Geschichte stattfindet,
weil es auf der einen Seite sind zwar studentische Proteste,
man muss aber dazu sagen, die Ressource für all das ist zivilgesellschaftlich getragen.
Das heißt, ob jetzt Essen, Trinken, Fahrten, alles Mögliche,
das ist an Sachen, wird von zivilgesellschaftlich getragen.
Das heißt, Menschen gehen da täglich hin, bringen Essen hin,
bringen Kleidung hin, bringen Sachen, die einfach notwendig sind, Prinzipien.
Und das heißt, da siehst du aber, dass es im Endeffekt ganz,
also deswegen kann man nicht sagen, es ist rein studentisch,
sondern natürlich zivilgesellschaftlich, gesamtgesellschaftlich muss man es betrachten.
Und da ist schon die Frage wiederum, wenn man also sieht, was da demokratisch
so stattfindet, dann ist schon die Frage, wie positioniert sich die EU oder
Europa zu diesen ganzen Bewegungen? Und da guckt man schon drauf.
Also welche Schlagzeilen gibt es? Wird darüber geschrieben überhaupt?
Wer spricht mit Vucic, wer spricht mit Studentinnen und so weiter und da ist natürlich schon die.
Sachlage die, dass man Europa eher schon so wahrgenommen hat aufgrund der einfach
Abkommen, die es gab und auch die Treffen, die es gab,
eben mit Vucic auch jetzt in den letzten Wochen, Monaten, dass man schon eher
Europa auf der Seite von Vucic sieht, weil sie ihn auch eben als Top-Menschen
irgendwie oder Top-Verhandler, wie auch immer vorgestellt haben,
also es gibt ja genug auch Statements von der Thunderline oder eben auch mit
Scholz, der da war, es war auch der,
auch vor ein paar Jahren war auch mal der Gerhard Schröder da.
Das heißt, also es gibt da so einige Dinge, wo man aber sieht,
okay, wenn die halt mit Vucic kooperieren und zusammenarbeiten und denen scheinbar
als jemanden betrachten, den man gemeinsam Geschäfte machen kann,
dann scheinen sie dementsprechend nicht auf unserer Seite zu sein.
Und dann scheinen sie dementsprechend einfach mit dem, was sie tun,
eigentlich dem entgegenzuwirken, was wir halt versuchen hier zu erreichen und
zu einem demokratischen Land.
Und das ist natürlich schon etwas, was sehr skeptisch betrachtet wird.
Und deswegen war diese Aktion, die man versucht hat, jetzt mit diesem Fahrradfahren durch,
verschiedene Länder Europas, war zum einen so gedacht von Studentinnen,
dass man medial in Europa die Aufmerksamkeit auf die Sache lenkt,
weil sie sich medial kaum Beachtung findet, also nicht ansatzweise in Relation
zu dem, was tatsächlich da stattfindet, finde ich.
Aber ich kann nachvollziehen, wie es medial so ist, weil die Medien auch wiederum
in gewisser Art und Weise funktionieren. Das habe ich mittlerweile auch verstanden und gelernt.
Und politisch genauso wie nicht. Und deswegen war dieses durch die Fahrradtour,
die sie neulich hatten, also es sind 80 Studentinnen,
ein Schüler war davon dabei, es waren im Endeffekt aus Novi Sad,
über Belgrane usw., sind im Endeffekt nach Straßburg gefahren durch verschiedene Länder.
Und haben dann darüber erstmal die Serb-Indusiaspora besucht,
haben mit Universitäten, also Universitätsstätten, haben sie Halt gemacht,
versucht mit Studenten da in Kontakt zu treten und da einen Austausch aufzubauen,
also auch da wiederum europäisch
eben irgendwo ein Netzwerk zu knüpfen und dann wiederum einfach auch zu gucken
und zu sagen, hey, wir gehen jetzt darauf.
Das heißt also, die Idee ist schon gewesen, vielleicht die EU,
Europa irgendwie nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, schon mal her, uns gibt es,
das sind unsere Anliegen, wir stehen ein für demokratische Werte und eigentlich
auch die Werte, für die hier einsteht.
Und wie steht ihr jetzt dazu und wiefern wollt ihr euch da positionieren?
Also so ein Subtext ist da auf jeden Fall mit drin und aus meiner Sicht,
persönlich in Einordnung, als ich in Belgrad war.
War ich in der Philosophischen Fakultät bei einem Gespräch mit der Professori
mit dabei, die gesagt hat, dass sie schon enttäuscht ist,
wie wenig eigentlich Europa sich da einschaltet und eigentlich Solidarität zeigt
und dass sie sich irgendwo schon auch alleingelassen fühlt.
Und das war übrigens mit ein Grund für mich, ein Plakat zu machen,
wo eben draufsteht, ich bin auch bei den Stuttgart, in Stuttgart gewesen,
bei dem Empfang der Studentin im Fahrrad, habe ich ein Plakat gehabt,
wo draufstand, dass die Europäische Zivilgesellschaft mit den Studenten ist und sie unterstützt.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das so ein bisschen ein kleines Problem ist,
dass EU-PolitikerInnen, die eigentlich diese Deals machen und dann eben aus
ihrer Position heraus kommunizieren, dass die als Stellvertretende für Europa verstanden werden.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass zivilgesellschaftlich betrachtet in Europa
unfassbar viele Menschen das begrüßen und das unterstützen, was da eigentlich stattfindet.
Aber kein Kanal da ist, um das zu kommunizieren.
Und deswegen ist für mich tatsächlich so, wäre es so ein zentrales Anliegen,
es irgendwie zu schaffen, dass dann bei der Zivilgesellschaft vielleicht irgendwo
auch nochmal stärker sich einschaltet, in gewisser Art und Weise.
Vielleicht auch über die Hochschulen. Das heißt, wir können ja zum Beispiel
sagen, als Hochschulen in Deutschland und Europa schreiben wir auch offene Briefe
und kommunizieren auch um unsere Solidarität zum Beispiel.
Das würde sicher unten gelesen und anerkannt werden. Wir können ja auch sagen,
als Hochschulen zum Beispiel treten wir demokratische Werte ein.
Als Wiesgesellschaft treten wir dafür ein zum Beispiel und macht einen Druck
auch politisch prinzipiert zum Beispiel. Würde auch funktionieren.
Also alles sind Dinge, die zum Beispiel schon, glaube ich, gesehen und wahrgenommen werden würden.
Und glaube ich einfach, die Leute auch unten nochmal stärken würden.
Weil aktuell ist schon so, glaube ich, dieses Gefühl von,
wir werden hier eingelassen und letzten Endes werden wir von der EU nur wahrgenommen
als Spielball in so einer ökonomischen Gleichung,
wo wir dann einfach ein Lithium haben, was irgendwie dann eben Deutschland dient,
um die Autoindustrie in Bezug auf diese Geschichte irgendwie zu fördern und
Unabhängigkeit zu bekommen.
Vielleicht von China oder von anderen Ländern, so einen geopolitischen Kontext
vielleicht, so ein kleiner Faktor in so einer Gleichung zu sein und gar nicht
als Menschen, die in Demokratie leben wollen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, so, würde ich jetzt von meiner sehr,
sehr persönlichen, sehr subjektiven Wahrnehmung in Worte fassen.
Ja, nachvollziehbare Sichtweise. Ich denke einfach, dass Serbien einfach gerade
nicht sonderlich auf der Agenda ist Und es aber in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich
auch wichtig wäre, dass diese Bewegung zum Erfolg führt.
Weil ich glaube, das Letzte, was die EU sich jetzt noch eintreten möchte,
ist nochmal so ein zweites Ungarn.
Und ich denke auch, bevor das Problem mit Ungarn nicht gelöst ist,
und zwar nicht nur in Bezug auf Ungarn, sondern generell.
Also da steht ja eigentlich eine Reform im Raum, von der man jetzt noch nicht
genau wüsste, wie man sie umsetzen soll.
Aber ich denke, es wird keine weiteren Aufnahmen in die EU geben,
bevor man nicht eine Regelung gefunden hat, wie man auch Staaten wieder rausschmeißen
kann, uns mal salopp zu formulieren.
Also das Orban-Problem hängt glaube ich so ein bisschen wie so ein Damoklesschwert
über dieser ganzen Debatte.
Aber das andere ist halt eben, dass glaube ich auch in Europa einfach die Wahrnehmung
für Serbien nicht stark ist oder zumindest natürlich nach wie vor sehr geprägt
ist von dem Jugoslawien-Kriegen,
der Rolle, die Serbien da mit Milosevic gespielt hat. Sowas hängt natürlich lange nach.
Kein Wunder, Deutschland, wir leiden ja auch immer noch unter Zweiter Weltkrieg
und so weiter, das wird auch so schnell nicht weggehen, ist vielleicht auch
ganz gut so, aber sowas kriegt man eben nicht so eben mal weg. Aber.
Das, also vielleicht mal anders gefragt, klar, man nimmt ja EU immer als Europa
wahr, hast du ja auch gerade gesagt, oder die Politiker sogar auch,
aber Europa ist ja noch mehr als jetzt nur die EU.
Und insofern frage ich mich eben, was ist dein Eindruck, wie die Serben sich da sehen?
Also das geht natürlich jetzt speziell mit Blick auf die Rolle gegenüber Russland.
Es gibt ja so eine Verbindung nach Russland und zwar auch jetzt,
jenseits der spezifischen Mafia-Verbindung, die wir vorhin diskutiert haben,
von Vucic und Autokraten unter sich, sondern rein kulturell gibt es ja eine
Verbindung nach Russland.
Wie ausgeprägt ist die und wie geht es der?
Weil ich habe die Wahrnehmung jetzt bekommen, in der Ukraine,
im Ukraine-Konflikt wo man vielleicht am Anfang erwartet hätte,
dass Serbien sich dann auch auf die russische Seite stellt,
in welchem Maße auch immer, dass das so nicht stattgefunden hat,
sondern dass das eigentlich eher dazu beigetragen hat, dass man jetzt auf Distanz geht zu Russland.
Ist meine Wahrnehmung da richtig?
Wie nimmst du das wahr?
Es ist mega komplex, weil ich kenne so viele verschiedene Kontexte von Menschen
aus dem Lebensalltag in Serbien, die wahrscheinlich auf diese Frage,
wie du sie stellst, sehr unterschiedlich antworten würden.
Das heißt, ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall eine historische, kulturelle Verbindung
zu Russland, also nicht nur sprachlich.
Das heißt, da gibt es echt einiges, was die verbindet.
Ich möchte aber leicht einen Gedanken dazu formulieren ich habe ja vorhin über
diese Aktion gesprochen, wo die 80 Studentinnen mit dem Fahrrad gefahren sind,
die sind nicht umsonst nach Straßburg gefahren und nicht nach Moskau,
das heißt, das ist doch auch eine klare Botschaft, finde ich also die hätten
ja auch sagen können, wir fahren mit dem Fahrrad nach Moskau,
haben sie aber nicht gemacht und bei aller,
Kritik und bei aller Diskrepanz in der Wahrnehmung der EU und Wahrnehmung Europas
und Wahrnehmung was weiß ich was und auch tatsächlich Uneinigkeit im Inhalt der Studenten.
Da gibt es verschiedene Gruppierungen, die unterschiedliches sehen für die Zukunft Serbiens.
Ist ja auf jeden Fall das zumindest etwas gewesen, was scheinbar einen Konsens
oder einen Konsensbestand zu sagen, wir fahren nach Straßburg.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, dass die Zukunft Serbiens, Ich glaube schon,
dass die es da in Europa sehen, aber halt, wie ich es vorhin gesagt habe, auf Augenhöhe.
Und wenn du sagst, eh mit Ungarn und da muss man gucken, wer jetzt noch hinzukommt,
da muss ich jetzt nicht nochmal sagen...
Das stimmt alles. Zeitgleich stimmt auch, dass es nicht Ungarn nur ist,
sondern viele andere EU-Länder, wo man durchaus sehr kritisch betrachten kann,
welche demokratischen Strukturenprozesse liegen denn da vor.
Das heißt, genauso kann man sich Deutschland zum Beispiel betrachten.
Das ist das, was mich am meisten so umtreibt, was mich so irre macht.
Wenn ich schaue, was in Serbien vorliegt, also die Kernprobleme,
die versuchen, die Studentinnen anzugehen, also angefangen vom öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk bis über Vertrauen, gar kein Vertrauen in die Politik,
weder in die Regierende als die Opposition,
also die Vertrauenskrise und viele andere Faktoren, dann sehe ich die in Deutschland genauso.
Und zwar immer stärker in die Richtung gehend. Und das ist das,
was mich zum Beispiel sorgt.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, inwiefern das zum Beispiel hier wahrgenommen wird.
Und weil man immer auf der einen Seite das Gefühl hat, man ist hier so stabil
und so sicher und die beste Demokratie und zeitgleich sehe ich aber schon sehr
starke Entwicklungen, die mich.
Tatsächlich für mich sehr besorgniserregend sind, wobei tatsächlich nicht ausreichend
die ernst genommen werden.
Und deswegen ist für mich tatsächlich so der Punkt, wenn man von der EU spricht
und Zukunft der EU spricht, dann muss man auch im Kontext dessen schauen,
dass Demokratien in der EU tatsächlich auch selbst sich nochmal weiterentwickeln
und stärken und schützen.
Und da gibt es genug Baustellen, die man im Prinzip auch dann da nochmal angehen kann.
Und da ist für mich tatsächlich der Schnittpunkt, wo ich sagen würde,
ich glaube, dass man manches da von denen lernen könnte.
Also für mich tatsächlich das, was gerade stattfindet, finde ich sehr,
also für mich ist richtig das Progressivste gerade, was ich kenne in Bezug auf
demokratische Entwicklungen.
Weil letzten Endes, wenn man es mal genau hinschaut, das hast du in Serbien.
Du hast junge Menschen,
die eine Bewegung anführen. Junge Menschen, also etwas, was jetzt im autokratischen,
globalen Kontext etwas ist, was gar keine Rolle spielt, wo völlig drüber gefahren wird.
Also schau mal jetzt in Deutschland, welche Rolle junge Menschen in Deutschland
spielen. Und nicht nur Deutschland, sondern überall, global.
Das heißt, junge Menschen sind etwas, was eigentlich gar keine Rolle spielt.
Zweitens, akademischer Kreis, das heißt, das sind Studentinnen.
Also wissenschaftlich, akademischer Bereich wird geschätzt und hochgehalten.
Auch wiederum völlig entgegen all dem, was wir global gerade haben.
Das heißt, in Zeiten, wo Wissenschaftsleuten stattfinden, wo in dem Fall False
Balance und so weiter verherrscht, also ist tatsächlich alles,
was da stattfindet gerade, ist das Gegenteil von dem, was du gerade an global hast.
Und deswegen ist es für mich ja so inspirierend und auch so interessant zu gucken
und zu sagen, kann man nicht da was von abgucken?
Und weil letzten Endes scheint es ja etwas bewegt zu haben oder gegründet zu
haben oder initiiert zu haben, was man sich eigentlich ja wieder wünscht.
Das heißt, ich würde mir wünschen, in Deutschland zu leben, wo Wissenschaft
hochgehalten wird. Ich würde mir wünschen, in Deutschland zu leben,
wo Jugend gehört wird, wo die Jugend eine starke Rolle spielt,
wo Zivilgesellschaft eine starke Rolle spielt.
Wir haben ja auch da wiederum, wenn man guckt, dieses gegen NGO schießen,
auch das, ob jetzt Trump oder Deutschland hier mit Glück, also egal wer,
du hast auch da wiederum, also all das, was jetzt gerade gut und stark ist und
da läuft, ist alles entgegen dem, was gerade schlecht läuft oder angegriffen
wird in den anderen Staaten, die jetzt noch Demokratien sind oder Demokratie waren.
Also USA-Demokratie ist nicht mehr bezeichnend, ja, ich bin,
aber jetzt in Deutschland würde ich sagen, die haben definitiv eine Demokratie
und immer noch, glaube ich, eine funktionierende Demokratie und.
Mein Einliegen wäre es, das eigentlich weiterhin noch zu haben.
Das heißt, ich würde sehr gerne hier in einem Land leben, was weiterhin demokratisch
wäre und vor allem auch im Kontext, im geopolitischen Kontext,
wenn man sieht, was jetzt mit den USA tatsächlich zerbrochen ist,
auch tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht irreparabel an geopolitischen,
an diesen Machtverhältnissen,
glaube ich, dass es ein starkes Europa braucht, was auch meiner Sicht auch viele
andere jetzt auch erkannt haben, dass es ein starkes Europa braucht.
Und umso mehr braucht es also auch starke demokratische Länder innerhalb der EU oder in Europa.
Das heißt, das Ziel muss auf jeden Fall sein, dass man eigentlich demokratische
Kräfte international viel stärker vernetzt und da einfach voneinander lernt.
Das macht, was demokratische Kräfte seit vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten schon tun.
Weil die vernetzen sich und die lernen voneinander.
Das heißt, da muss man nur das Buch von Annika Brockschmidt lesen,
Amerikas Gotteskrieger, oder auch was sie nachgeschrieben hat.
Da siehst du ja wunderbar diese Netzwerke, wie global die funktionieren.
Tatsächlich auch auf dem Balkan hinaus. Das heißt, die gehen wirklich global.
Da gehen ja überall rein, ganz gezielt. Und genauso muss aus meiner Sicht eben
die demokratische Gesellschaft sich auch vernetzen und voneinander lernen und
eben da gemeinsam aktiv werden.
Stimme ich dir natürlich total zu und ich wollte auch überhaupt nicht,
ausdrücken, dass hier in Deutschland alles supi ist also gerade in Bezug auf
Russland deswegen spreche ich das glaube ich auch an, verstört mich natürlich hier diese latente,
Russlandliebe würde ich es jetzt mal nicht nennen, aber es gibt so eine wie
soll ich sagen es ist so ein bisschen ähm,
So ein vorgeschobenes, latent-antidemokratisches Gefühl, was sich so breit macht,
was dann irgendwie so sich an Russland ein bisschen festmacht.
Und das ist halt jetzt gerade im Osten Deutschlands, aber beileibe nicht nur
im Osten Deutschlands, verbreitet, dass man immer sagt, ja, ist ja alles gar
nicht so schlimm und das ist ja alles nur eine Darstellung der Medien.
Und was den Leuten halt alles noch irgendwie so einfällt.
Ich meine, Ostdeutschland hatte natürlich auch enge Verbindungen zu Russland
durch die Zeit der DDR und insofern ist vielleicht auch gerade Ostdeutschland
auch so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit Serbien. Darauf wollte ich halt so ein bisschen hinaus.
Also wie viel hängt da noch in der Bevölkerung drin, weil ich mir vorstellen
kann, dass das auch so ein Teil ist, der noch überwunden werden muss.
Oh, da muss viel bewunden werden. Da muss viel bewunden werden.
Also du hast viel auch so toxische Männlichkeitsbilder.
Also tatsächlich auch so alles, was irgendwie mit auch Rassismus,
Feminismus. Also alle Bereiche, die hier baustellen, sind sie natürlich da auch
baustellen und teilweise viel größere Baustellen.
Aber das ist ja der Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, was die Studenten wiederum auch da so vorleben.
Also auch dieses, die haben zum Beispiel jetzt ein paar so Aktionen gehabt,
wo sie eben diesen, mit diesem muslimischen Teil der Serbien zum Beispiel gemeinsam gefeiert haben.
Die muslimischen Serbinnen wiederum, die christlichen Serbinnen wiederum auch
eben ihre Bräuche und so weiter, Anerkennung gefeiert haben.
Das heißt, dass man dieses Zueinander finden.
Und das ist vielleicht auch für mich so, was man von ihnen lernen könnte,
ist, dass die eigentlich wiederum sehr stark sagen, lass uns mal nicht wieder
uns auseinander dividieren in wer Russland und was weiß ich was, sondern eher dieses,
welche Menschen stehen dahinter und was, also das wirklich alles,
was diese ganzen Kategorien von Ethnie,
Nationalität, Religion, was auch immer.
Dass man die zur Seite schiebt und sagt, okay, lass uns mal davon ausgehen,
dass wir eigentlich alle in einem freien Land leben wollen, in dem es allen gut geht.
Und das ist die Prämisse. Das heißt, die fordern letztendlich einen Rechtsstaat,
in dem alle gleichwertig behandelt werden.
Die fordern einen Rechtsstaat, der eben nicht auf diese ganzen Faktoren schaut.
Und letztendlich fordern sie auch wiederum mit dem, habe ich in verschiedenen Podcasts rausgehört.
Auch diese Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Ländern, verstehen die genauso.
Das heißt also auch in der EU, wäre es dann sowieso sagen würde,
EU ja, aber dann eben auch für alle gleich.
Das heißt, dass einfach alle gleichwertig betrachtet werden und wiederum auch
da keine irgendwie strukturellen Machtverhältnisse geschaffen werden,
die wiederum ungerecht sind.
Und das ist tatsächlich der Punkt, wo ich jetzt sagen würde,
auch in Bezug auf Russland und anderen würde ich auch sagen,
man muss immer trennen zwischen einem Staat und Menschen, die diesen Staat bestimmen
und prägen und den Menschen, die in diesem Staat leben.
Und ich finde es immer so schade, dass man hier sehr stark darauf geht,
auf dieses, was die trennt, auch geschichtlich, was da vorgefallen ist,
bei allem, was es auch einen Raum braucht und richtig ist, und darüber zu sprechen.
Zeitgleich der Blick nach vorne muss für mich sein, wenn wir sagen,
und ich habe vorhin gesagt, lass uns mal geoglisch drauf gucken und sagen,
wir haben eine ökonomische Brille auf und mit dem Autokrad, den ich vorhin beschrieben habe,
mit der gleichen Brille kann ich auch sagen, wir müssen eigentlich auch eine
Welt uns vorstellen, in der Menschen auf der ganzen Welt miteinander in Frieden
leben wollen und alle ein vernünftiges Leben haben, vernünftiges Einkommen haben,
nicht Länder, andere Länder ausbeuten.
Das heißt, du musst also eine Welt schaffen, in dem Fall das,
was die jetzt gerade in den Kosmos Serbien versuchen, um die so voranzutreiben,
das zu skalieren auf eine globale Ebene.
So sagen, hey, es muss doch machbar sein, dass alle Menschen irgendwo frei sein
können, dass alle Menschen in dem Fall ein würdevolles Leben führen können und
ein friedvolles Leben führen können, wo zum Beispiel auch Gewalt,
was ich vorhin zum Beispiel gesagt habe, Gewalt eben keine Form,
keine Option darstellt.
Und das ist für mich etwas, wo ich jetzt für mich rausziehe,
zu sagen, ich schaue mir so drauf, wie würden die das sagen,
wie würden die das denken.
Mit der Brille gucke ich ein bisschen drauf und versuche alles,
was dieses Trennen, Kategorisieren Prinzip hat, das nicht mehr zu überwinden,
weil letzten Endes haben die tatsächlich das gemacht.
Das heißt, sie haben für sich verstanden, dass Autokratien so funktionieren,
dass im Endeffekt Menschen permanent getrennt werden, in verschiedene Schichten,
verschiedene Bereiche.
Und du hast dann diese Partikulär Interessen. Und dann wird dir auch so gesagt,
du gehörst zu der Gruppe, du gehörst zu der Gruppe.
Und letzten Endes verhindert das, dass du dich als Menschen verbindest,
dass du solidarisch bist und dann checkst du, eigentlich haben wir an ziemlich
vielen Stellen die gleichen Probleme.
Und eigentlich wollen wir ziemlich viele von uns das Gleiche.
Und letzten Endes ist es genau so der Punkt. Das heißt, eigentlich könntest
du global sagen, so 80, 90 Prozent der Leute haben eigentlich die gleichen Probleme.
Und eigentlich könnte man die gemeinsam angehen. Wenn man nicht von den neun
oder zehn Prozent, ein Prozent der Bevölkerung, die dementsprechend diese Macht besitzt,
immer wieder unterteilen lassen, verschiedene Gruppierungen und dann uns dann
an Sachen, uns gegeneinander bekämpfen und dann gucken so, weißt du, wie ich meine?
Das ist so etwas, was ich für mich am meisten daraus gelernt habe.
Teile und Herrscher, also das ist halt das Prinzip.
Ich meine, das sieht man ja auch jetzt in den USA generell, das ist halt immer das Prinzip,
mach einfach Feinde aus und teile die Leute in irgendwelche Gruppen,
die es gar nicht gibt, sodass sie sich permanent gegenseitig bekämpfen,
damit sie das eigentliche Problem nicht angehen.
Was halt immer die ungleichmäßig verteilte Macht ist.
Ja, Dejan, ich denke, damit haben wir es eigentlich ganz gut abgeräumt, das Thema erstmal.
Das geht halt alles weiter.
Du bist ja ganz fleißig am Schreiben auf Mastodorn.
Mastodorn, wenn irgendwas passiert, gibt es da noch andere deutsche oder internationale
englische Quellen, die man nennen und in den Shownotes packen müsste,
um sich da irgendwie eine Quelle erschließen zu können für weitere Ereignisse?
Weißt du da irgendwas? Oder bist du der Einzige?
Nein, es gibt einfach Menschen, die es beruflich machen und sich da deutlich
besser auskennen als ich.
Also zum Beispiel Olivera Stajic, die arbeitet für den Standard und der Standard
schreibt auch immer wieder mal darüber, die kann man auf jeden Fall verfolgen.
Die Tanja Malle, die ist auch beim Ü1, glaube ich, die ist auch da sehr bewandert
und immer gut dabei und auch sehr klug.
Es gibt dann auch den Christo Lazarevic, der ist zum Beispiel auch damals auch
mit mir im Belgrad gewesen, auch am 15. hat darüber auch berichtet.
Es gibt Ich glaube, einige Akteure, die man da noch etwas nennen kann.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man erst mal den drei folgt, es gibt noch,
wie gesagt, weitaus mehr, die ich jetzt sicher vergessen habe.
Aber ja...
Irgendwann sind Journalistinnen. Das heißt, sind einfach Leute,
die einfach ihr Fach verstehen. Wie gesagt, man darf nicht vergessen,
ich bin einfach nur Mensch mit Internet.
Ich auch. Von daher alles in Ordnung.
Vielen Dank für deinen Beitrag auf jeden Fall. Wir werden die Links zu den genannten
Personen und Quellen auf jeden Fall hier noch in die Show Notes packen.
Ja, und ich würde sagen, das war's. Vielen Dank, Dian.
Ich danke dir. Ich danke dir vor allem, dass du der Thematik den Raum gegeben
hast, deine Zeit und die Fragen.
Das heißt, da bin ich für dich sehr dankbar, weil ich tatsächlich eben,
du siehst ja selber, Teil des Problems ist ja eben diese mediale,
überschaubare Präsenz und dementsprechend ist einfach jeder Beitrag,
der dazu beisteuert, dass Menschen einfach wahrnehmen, was da stattfindet und
welche Menschen da im Entwurf leben oder auch leben, ist auch etwas,
was glaube ich notwendig ist und wo ich sehr dankbar dafür bin. Deswegen vielen Dank.
Ja, gern geschehen. Dafür ist ja UKW auch gedacht, hier als kleiner Krisen-Podcast und so.
Und es ist ja auch immer schön, mal Entwicklungen zu sehen, die so in die positive Richtung zeigen.
Alright, gut, das war's. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier geht's auch bald wieder.
Weiter. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.